Hey, this is Andrew Brown, your cloud instructor
exam Pro, and I'm bringing you another complete
study course. And this time, it's the Azure
AI fundamentals made available here on Free
Code Camp. So this course is designed to help
you pass the exam and achieve Microsoft issued
certification. And we're going to do that
by providing you great lecture content,
follow along to get that hands on experience,
and cheat sheets for the day of your exam.
So when you do get that certification,
you can put it on your resume or LinkedIn,
and show that you have that ASHRAE knowledge
to get that cloud job or get that promotion.
So I want to introduce myself, I'm previously the
CTO of multiple edtech companies with 15 years,
industry experienced five years specializing
cloud service community hero, and I've published
many free cloud courses. I love Star Trek and
coconut water. So I just want to take a moment
here to thank viewers like you, because it's
you that make these free courses possible.
And if you want to support more
free courses, just like this one,
a great way to do that is buying our additional
study materials on exam pro.co. And for this exam,
it's Ford slash ai 900. This will get you
access to study notes, flashcards, quizlets,
downloadable cheat sheets and practice exams. And
you'll also be able to ask questions and get some
learning support. So if you want to keep up to
date with any of the more courses I am releasing,
you can follow me on twitter at Andrew, Andrew
route 10 share with me when you pass the exam,
or what you might like to see as the next
course. So there we go. Let's get to it.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And we
are at the start of our journey here learning
about the AI 900 asking the most important
question which is what is the a 900. So the
Azure AI fundamentals certification is for
those seeking in ML roles such as AI engineer
or data scientists. And the certification will
demonstrate a person can define and understand
Azure cognitive services, ai concepts, knowledge
mining, responsible AI basis of ml pipelines,
classical ml models, auto ml and Azure ML
studio. So you don't need to know super
complicated ml knowledge here, but definitely
helps to get you through there. But yeah,
so this certification is generally referred to by
its course code, the AIA 900 into the natural path
for the Azure AI engineer or Azure Data Scientist
certification. And this generally is an easy
course to pass. It's great for those new to cloud
or ml related technology, looking at our roadmap,
you might be asking, okay, well, what are the
paths? And what should I learn. And so here are
my markers. And let's get out the annotation tool
or laser pointer to see where we can go. Now if
you already have your az 900. That's a great
starting point before you take your ai 900.
If you don't have your az 900, you can jump right
into the 900. But I strongly recommend you go get
that az 900 because it gives you General, General,
foundational knowledge, it's just another thing
that you should not have to worry about, which is
just how to use Azure at a fundamental level. Do
you need the DP 900 to take the 900 No, but a lot
of people seem to like to to go this route where
they want to have that data foundation before they
move on to a to the AI 100 because they know that
that is just broad knowledge is going to be useful
there. So you know, it is apparent that you see
a lot people getting the AI 900 and the DPI 900.
Together, vana 100, the path is a little bit more
clear, it's either going to be data scientists or
AI engineer. So AI engineer is just the cognitive
services turned up to 11, you have to know how to
use the AI services in and out for data scientists
is more focused on setting up actual pipelines,
and things like that within the Azure Machine
Learning Studio. So you just have to decide which
path is for you. The data scientist is definitely
harder than the AI engineer, I think the coaches
was updated. So I just updated that to 102.
And I think the AI engineers to be two
separate, you had to take two separate
courses. But now it's just a
single one. So it's unified.
But you know, if you aren't ready for the data
sciences, some people like taking the AI engineer
first and then doing the data scientist. So this
is kind of like a warm up. Again, it's not 100%
necessary, but it's just based on your personal
learning style. And a lot of times people like to
take the data engineer after the data scientists
just to round out their complete knowledge. Now,
if you already have the az 900 and the associate,
you can safely go to the data scientist if you
want to risk it, because this one is really
hard. So if you've passed the easy one before,
you know, you're gonna probably have a lot more
confidence, learning about this stuff, all this
fun foundational stuff at this level here. But of
course, it's always recommended to go grab these
foundational certs because sometimes course
materials just do not cover that information.
And so the obvious stuff is going to get left out.
Okay. So moving forward here. So how long should
you study to pass for the 900? Well, if you have
one year's experience with Azure, you're looking
at five hours as little as five hours could be
up to 10 hours. If you have passed the az 900
to dp 900. Around 10 hours is the average. If
you're completely new to ml AI, you're looking
at 15 hours, this could get extended to 20 to 30
Again, it just depends on how green you are like
how new you are to these concepts. But you know,
I think on average, we're looking at 15 hours,
the recommended study time is 30 minutes a
day for 14 days should get you through it.
You know, but, you know, just don't over study
and just don't spend too little time, you know.
So where do you take this example, you can take
it in person at a test center or online from
the convenience of your own home. So there's two
popular test centers, there's psi and Pearson VUE,
well, and I should say these are theirs. These are
not necessarily test centers, per se, but they are
a collection of test centers that are partnered
with psi Pearson VUE so that you can easily take
it at a local test center. If you ever heard
the term Proctor that is that means a supervisor
person that is monitoring you while you're taking
the exam to them. When we talk about online exams,
they'll say proctored exams to refer to the online
component, if I had the option to meet in person
online, always the in person because it's a
controlled environment, it's way less stress us
stress stressful. And, you know, online, there can
so many things can go wrong. So you know, but it's
up to your personal preference and your situation.
Okay? What does it take to pass the exam? Well,
you got to watch the lectures, and memorize key
information, do hands on labs and follow along
with your own Azure account, I would say that you
could probably get away with just watching all the
videos in this one without having to do but again,
you know, it really does reinforce information.
If you do take the time there. There is some
stuff that is an Azure Machine Learning Studio,
you might be wary of launching because we do have
to run instances and they will cost money. So if
you if you feel that you're not comfortable with
that, just watching you should be okay. But when
you get into the associate tier you absolutely you
just have to expect to pay something to to learn
and take that risk, okay? You want to do paid
online practice exams that simulate the real exam.
So I do have paid practice exams that accompany
this course that are on my platform exam Pro.
And that's how you can help support more of
these free courses. Can you pass this without
taking practice exam Asher's a little bit harder?
If this is an AWS exam? I'd say yes. for Azure.
It's kind of risky, the easy 100 Sure. Ai 900 dP
900 sC 900? No, I think you should get a practice
exam, at least one, or go through the sample one,
there's a sample one probably looking around for
on the Azure website. Let's just look at the exam
guide break down here very shortly. And then in
the following video, we'll look at in more detail.
So it's broken down into the following domains to
describe AI workloads and considerations describe
fundamental principles of machine learning
on Azure describe features of computer vision
workloads on Azure, describe features of natural
language processing workloads on Azure, describe
features of conversational AI workloads on Azure.
And I want you to notice it says describe,
describe, describe, describe, describe, that's
good, because that tells you it's not going to
be super, super hard, right? If you start seeing
things that say, beyond describing identify,
then you know, it's going to be a bit harder,
okay? The passing grade here is 700 out of
1000. So that's around 70 70%, I would say
around because you could possibly fail with 70%.
Because these things work on scaled scoring. For
response types, there's about 40 to 60 questions,
and you can afford to get 12 to 18 questions
wrong. I put an asterisk there because there's not
always just one question per like, per section,
but I'll talk about the here in a second. So some
questions are worth more than one point. There's
no penalty for wrong questions. Some questions
cannot be skipped. And the format of questions
can be multiple choice, multiple answer, drag and
drop hot area case studies. Case Studies. I don't
remember I don't think I saw a case study on mind.
But case studies will have a series of questions,
a series of questions that make up or come back
to a particular business problem. And so those are
very interesting. That's why we have that asterik
up here, okay. So for the duration, you get one
hour, that means about one minute per question.
The time for this exam is 60 minutes, your seat
time is 90 minutes, seat time refers to the
amount of time that you should take to allocate
for that exam. So this includes time to review the
instructions, read, accept the NDA, complete the
exam and provide feedback at the exam. This is
going to be valid for 24 months up to two years
before we have certification. And, you know,
we'll proceed to the full exam guide now. Okay.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And what
we've pulled up here is the official exam outline
on the Microsoft website. If you want to find
this yourself, just got to type in ai 100, Azure
or Microsoft, you should be able to easily find
it, the page looks like this. And what I want
you to do is scroll on down because we're looking
for skills measured and from there, we're going
to download the skills outline. And once we have
that open, you might want to bump up the text. And
so what you'll always see in these documents is a
red text at the top saying hey, we've updated the
track as your loves updating their courses with
minute updates that don't generally affect the
outcome of the study. But it does get a lot
people worrying. So we say, well, is your core
set of data? So no, no, they're just making minor
changes. Because they'll do this like five times
a year. And so if there was a major revision,
what would happen is they would change it. So
instead of being the AI 900, to be like, the
AI 901, or 9902, we saw that recently with the,
the AI 100 words now the ai, ai 102 or 103.
Sorry. So you know, just watch out for those.
And if it's a major revision, then yes, the
course you would need a completely new course,
and it would not match. But for minors, it's
going to be my new thing. So if we scroll on down,
and a lot of times, they'll just cross out
what they've changed in this one in particular,
they did not show us in detail, you'd
have to read through the comparison.
But we'll look at the new listing here. and work
our way through here is to describe artificial or
AI workloads and considerations. So here we
just kind of describing the generalities of
AI. So prediction forecasting, this is because
when we use auto ml prediction would be
classification and regression and forecasting
would be that real time series forecasting,
I suppose, identity features anomaly detection. So
not a lot in the exam for this. So we we touched
on it briefly, computer vision workloads, there's
a lot of stuff under computer vision, as you'll
find out through the course, and LP and knowledge,
mining workloads, conversational AI, workloads.
And again, these are all the concepts, not how to
use the services, then you have the responsible AI
section. And so Microsoft has these six principles
that they really want you to know. And they push
it throughout all their AI services. So those are
the 16 liter. Now, they're not that hard to learn,
then describe fundamental principles of machine
learning on Azure. So here, it's just describing
regression, classification and clustering. We
have a lot of practical experience with these
in the course. So you will understand
at the end what these are used for.
For core machine learning concepts, we can
identify features and labels in a data set.
So that's their data labeling service, describe
how training validation data sets are used in
machine learning. So we touch on that describe how
machine learning algorithms are used for training,
select and interpret model valuations of
metrics for classification regression,
a lot of these deal categories in auto ml because
it automatically does it, but we can see how it
does that. Okay. Well, I think having to
do it ourselves, identify core tasks and
creating a machine learning solution. So describe
common features of data ingestion, preparation,
feature engineering, selection,
features of model training, evaluation,
features of model deployment and management.
And then we have described no code solution. So
auto ml, they like to call it automated. ml,
but really, the industry just calls it auto ml.
Then there's the designer for building pipelines.
Here's where we see some changes. So identify
features of image classification, features
of object detection solution. So semantic
segmentation is gone, which is great, because I
don't even know what that is. So it's great that
it's out there, OCR solutions, and then you have
face detection. Then under computer vision tasks,
we have computer vision, custom vision, face
services form recognizer tones. There's a
lot around computer vision. For NLP we have key
phrase extraction, identity recognition, sentiment
analysis, language modeling, speech recognition,
synthesis, this one doesn't really appear much.
It's kind of a concept not so much something we
have to do. Then there's translation. We have nlp,
nlp stuff. So text analytics, Luis, or Louis,
I'm not sure which way to pronounce it. Speech
service and text, translator text. Then down
below below, we have a conversational AI. So
building out web chat bots, and characters of
conversation AI solutions looks like these two
have telephone and personal digital assistants
not sure why they decided to remove that. But
that's okay. I think that's fine. q&a maker and
Azure bot, I really like this service, by the way.
So yeah, there we go. That is the outline.
And now we'll jump into the actual course.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And we
are looking at the layers of machine learning. So
here I have this thing that looks
like kind of an onion. And what it is,
it's just describing the relationship
between these ml terms related to AI,
and we'll just work our way through here starting
at the top. So artificial intelligence, also known
as AI is when machines that perform jobs that
mimic human behavior. So it doesn't describe
how it does that. But it's just the fact
that that's what AI is one layer underneath
we have machine learning. So machines that get
better at a task without explicit programming.
Then we have deep learning. So these are machines
that have an artificial neural network inspired by
the human brain to solve complex problems. And
if you're talking about some of that actually
assembles either ml or deep learning models or
algorithms that's a data scientist or person with
multidisciplinary skills and math statistics,
predictive modeling machine learning to make
future predictions. So what you need to understand
is that AI is just the outcome, right? And so AI
could be using m Underneath, or deep learning, or
a combination of both or just FL statements, okay?
Alright, so let's take a look here at the
key elements of AI. So AI is the software
that imitates human behaviors and capabilities.
And there are key elements according to Azure
or Microsoft as to what makes up AI. So let's
go through this list quickly here. So we have
machine learning, which is the foundation of an
AI system that can learn predict like a human,
you have anomaly detection. So detect outliers or
things out of place, like a human computer vision,
be able to see like a human natural language
processing, also known as NLP, be able to
process human languages and refer a context, you
know, like a human, conversational AI be able to
hold a conversation with a human. So, you know,
I wrote here, according to Microsoft and Azure,
because you know, the global definition is a bit
different. But I just wanted to put this here,
because I've definitely seen this as an exam
question. And so we're going to have to go with
Asher's definition here. Okay. Let's define what
is a data set. So a data set is a logical grouping
of units of data that are closely related to
or share the same data structure. And there
are publicly available datasets that are used in
learning of statistics, data analytics and machine
learning. I just want to cover a couple here. So
the first is the M NIST database. So images of
handwritten digits use to test classify cluster
image processing algorithms commonly used when
learning how to build computer vision ml models
to translate handwritten into or handwriting into
digital text. So it's just a bunch of handwritten
numbers and letters. And then another very popular
data set is the common objects in context cocoa
dataset. So this is a dataset which contains
many common images using a JSON file, cocoa format
that identify objects or segments within an image.
And so this data set has a lot of stuff in its
object segmentations recognition and IP context,
super pixel stuff, segmentation, they have a lot
of images, and a lot of objects. So there's a lot
of stuff in there. So why am I talking about
this, and in particular cocoa data sets? Well,
when you use Azure Machine Learning Studio,
it has a daily data labeling service. And
the thing is, is that it can actually export out
into cocoa format. So that's why I want you to
get exposure to what cocoa was. And the other
thing is, is that when you're building out Azure
Machine Learning pipelines, you they actually have
open datasets, as you'll see later in the course,
that shows you that you can just
use very common ones. And so
you might see m NIST and the other one there.
So I just wanted to get you some exposure. Okay.
Let's talk about data labeling. So this
is the process of identifying raw data,
so images, text files, videos, and adding one
or more meaningful and informative labels to
provide context so a machine learning model
can learn. So with supervised machine learning,
labeling is a prerequisite to produce training
data. And each piece of data will generally be
labeled by a human. The reason why I say generally
here is because with Azure Data labeling service,
they can actually do ml assisted labeling. So
with unsupervised machine learning labels will
be produced by the machine and may not be human
readable. And then one other thing I want to touch
on is the term called ground truth. So this is
a proper, a properly labeled data set that you
can use as the objective standard to train and
assess a given model is often called ground truth,
the accuracy of your train model will depend on
the accuracy of your ground truth. Now using Azure
as tools I've ever seen and used that word ground
truth, I see that a lot in AWS, and even this
graphic here is from AWS. But I just want to make
sure you are familiar with all that stuff. Okay.
Let's compare supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning. Starting at the top,
we got supervised learning, this is where the data
has been labeled for training. And it's considered
task driven, because you're trying to make a
prediction get a value back. So when the labels
are known, and you want a precise outcome, when
you need a specific value returned, and so you're
going to be using classification and regression
in these cases. For unsupervised learning,
this is where data that has not been labeled,
the ML model needs to do its own labeling.
This is considered data driven. It's trying to
recognize a structure or a pattern. And so this
is when the labels are not known. And the outcome
does not need to be precise when you're trying
to make sense of data. So you have clustering,
dimensionality reduction and Association. Have
you ever heard this term before? The idea is it's
trying to reduce the amount of dimensions to make
it easier to work with the data. So make sense of
the data, right? We have reinforcement learning.
So this is where there is no data. There's
an environment and an ml model generates data
and makes many attempts to reach a goal. So this
is considered decisions driven. And so this is for
game AI learning tasks robot navigation, when
you've seen someone code In a video game that
can play itself, that's what this is. If you're
wondering, this is not all the types of machine
learning. And these specific, unsupervised
and supervised is considered classical machine
learning because they have heavily rely on
statistics and math to produce the outcome.
But there you go. So what is a neural network?
Well, it's often described as mimicking the brain,
it's a neuron or node that represents an
algorithm. So data is inputted into a neuron and
based on the output, the data will be passed to
one of many connected neurons, that it connections
between neurons is weighted, I really should
have highlighted that one that's very important.
The network is organized into layers, there will
be an input layer, one too many hidden layers and
an open layer. So here's an example of a very
simple neural network. Notice the nn, a lot of
times you'll see this in ML as an abbreviation for
neural networks. And sometimes neural networks are
just called neural nets. So just understand that's
the same term here. What is deep learning? This is
a neural network that has three or more hidden
layers, it's considered deep learning, because
at this point, it's it's not human readable to
understand what's going on within those layers.
What is Ford fried, so neural networks, where
they have connections between nodes that do not
form a cycle, they always move forward. So that's
just describes a forward pass through the network,
you'll see fn n, which stands for forward feed
neural network just described that type of
network, then there's about back propagation,
which are in forward feed networks. This is
where we move backwards through the neural net,
adjusting the weights to improve the outcome on
next iteration. This is how a neural net learns.
The way the backpropagation knows to do this
is that there's a loss function. So a function
that compared the ground true to the prediction
to determine the error rate how bad the network
performs. So when it gets to the end, it's going
to perform that calculation, and then it's going
to do its back propagation, adjust the weights,
then you have activation functions, I'm just going
to clear this up here. So activation functions.
They're an algorithm applied to a hidden
layer node that affects connected output. So
for this entire hidden layer, they'll all have
the same one here and just kind of affects
how it learns and like how the weighting works,
so it's part of backpropagation. And just the
learning process, there's a concept of dense so
when the next layer increases the amount of nodes
and you have a sparse so when the next layer
decreases the amount of notes. Anytime you
see something going from a dense layer to a
sparse later, that's usually called dimensional
dimensionality reduction because you're reducing
the amount of dimensions because the amount of
nodes in your network determines
the dimensions you have. Okay.
What is a GPU? Well, it's a general processing
unit that is specially designed to quickly render
high resolution images and videos concurrently.
GPUs can perform parallel operations on multiple
sets of data. So they are commonly used for non
graphical tasks such as machine learning, and
scientific computation. So a CPU has an average
of four to 16. processor cores, a GPU can have
1000s of processor cores, so something that has 48
GPUs can have as many as 40,000 cores. Here's an
image I grabbed right off the Nvidia website.
And so it really illustrates very well, like
how this would be really good for machine learning
or neural networks. Because neural networks have
a bunch of nodes. They're very repetitive tasks,
you can spread them across a lot of cores, that's
gonna work out really great. So GPUs are suited
for repetitive and highly parallel computing tasks
such as rendering, graphics, cryptocurrency
mining, deep learning and machine learning.
We're talking about CUDA before we can let's talk
about what Nvidia is. So Nvidia is a company that
manufactures graphical processing units for gaming
and professional markets. If you play video games,
you've heard of Nvidia. So what is CUDA? It is
the compute unified device architecture. It is
a parallel computing platform and API by Nvidia
that allows developers to use CUDA enabled GPUs
for general purpose computing on GPUs. So GP GPUs,
all major deep learning frameworks are integrated
with Nvidia deep learning SDK. The Nvidia deep
learning SDK is a collection of Nvidia libraries
for deep learning. One of those libraries is
the CUDA deep neural network library. So cu dnn
so CUDA, RC UD and n provide provides highly
tuned implementations for standard routine such as
forward and back convolution
convolutions really great for
computer vision, pooling normalization activation
layers. So, you know, in the Azure certification
for the AI 900. They're not going
to be talking about CUDA. But if
you understand these two things, you'll
understand why GPUs really matter. Okay.
All right, let's get a easy introduction
into machine learning pipeline. So this
one is definitely not an exhaustive one, and
we're definitely gonna see more complex ones
throughout this course. But let's get to
it here. So starting on the left hand side,
we might start with data labeling. This is very
important when you're doing supervised learning
because you need to to label your data set, the
ML model can learn by example, during training,
this stage and the feature engineers nearing
stage or is considered pre processing because
we are preparing our data to be trained for the
model. When we move on to feature engineering,
the idea here is that ml models can only work
with numerical data. So we need to translate it
into a format that it can understand. So extract
out the important data that the ML model needs to
focus on. Okay, then there's the training step. So
your model needs to learn how to become smarter,
it will perform multiple iterations
getting smarter with each iteration,
you might also have a hyper parameter tuning
step here, it says tuning but should say tuning.
But the ML model can have different parameters.
So you can use ml to try out many different
parameters to optimize the outcome. When you
get to deep learning, it's impossible to tweak
the parameters by hand. So you have to use hyper
parameter tuning, then you have serving, sometimes
known as deploying. But you know, when we say
deploy, we talked about the entire pipeline,
not necessarily just the ML model step. So
we need to make an ml model accessible. So we
serve it by hosting in a virtual machine or
container. When we're talking about Azure
machine learning, it's either going to be an Azure
Kubernetes service or Azure Container instance.
And you have inference. So inference is the act
of request, requesting to make a prediction,
so you send your payload with either CSV
or whatever, and you get back the results,
you have a real time endpoint and batch
processing. So real time, it's just
there they can batch can be real time as well.
But generally, it's slower. But the idea is that
do I? Am I making a single item prediction? Or am
I giving you a bunch of data at once. And again,
this is a very simplified ml pipeline, I'm sure
we'll revisit ml pipeline later in this course.
So let's compare the the terms forecasting and
prediction. So forecasting, you make a prediction
with relevant data. It's great for analysis
of trends, and it's not guessing. And when
you're talking about prediction, this is where you
make a prediction without relevant data, you use
statistics to predict future outcomes, it's
more of guessing. And he uses decision theory.
So imagine you have a bunch of data. And the
idea is you're going to infer from that data,
okay, maybe it's a, maybe it's B,
maybe it's C. And for prediction,
you don't have really much data, so you're
going to have to kind of invent it. And the
idea is that you'll figure out what the outcome
is there. These are extremely broad terms,
but you know, just so you have a high
level view of these two things, okay.
So what are performance or evaluation metrics?
Well, they are used to evaluate different machine
learning algorithms. So the idea is, you know,
when your machine learning makes a prediction,
these are the metrics you're using to evaluate
to determine, you know, is your ml model working
as you intended. So for different types of
problems, different metrics matter, this
is absolutely not an exhaustive list. I just want
you to get you exposure to these words and things
so that when you see them you go, Okay,
I'll come back here and refer to this.
But lots of these are just it's not you it's
not necessarily remember but classification
metrics you should know. So classification,
we have accuracy, precision recall f1 score,
rockin AUC. For regression metrics. We
have MSC, our MSC ma ranking metrics,
we have MLR, DCG and DCG. Statistical metrics,
we have correlation, computer vision metrics,
we have psnr, SSI m, IOU and LP metrics, we
have perplexity blue Meteor rogue, deep learning
related metrics. We have Inception score, I cannot
say this person's name, but or I'm assuming it's
a person but this Inception distance. And
there are two categories evaluation metrics,
we have internal evaluation. So metrics used to
evaluate the internals of an ml model. So accuracy
f1 score precision, recall, I call them the
famous for using all kinds of models and external
evaluation metrics used to evaluate the final
prediction of an ml model. So yeah, don't get too
worked up here. I know that's a lot of stuff.
The ones that matter, we will see again, okay.
Let's take a look at Jupiter notebook. So these
are web based applications for authoring documents
to combine live code narrative text equations,
visualizations. So if you're doing data science,
or you're building ml models, you apps
that are going to be working with Jupyter
notebooks. They're always integrated
into cloud service providers ml tools.
So Jupyter Notebook actually came about from
ipython. So ipython is the precursor of it. And
they extracted that feature out it became Jupyter
Notebook I bought ipython is now a kernel to run
Python. So when you execute Python code here,
it's using ipython, which is a version of Python
Jupyter Notebooks were overhauled and better
integrated into an ID called Jupiter labs,
which we'll talk about here in a moment. And
you generally want to open notebooks in labs,
the legacy web based interfaces known as
Jupiter classic notebooks. This is what the
old one looks like you still open them up,
but everyone uses Jupiter labs now. Okay,
so let's talk about Jupiter labs. Jupiter Labs is
the next generation web based user interface, all
familiar features of the classic
Jupyter Notebook is in a flexible,
powerful user interface. It has notebooks,
a terminal, a text editor, a file browser,
rich outputs, Jupiter labs will eventually replace
the classic Jupyter notebooks. So there you go.
We keep mentioning regression, but let's talk
about it in more detail here. So we kind of
understand the concept. So regression is the
process of finding a function. to correlate
a labeled data set gnosis is labeled, that
means it's going to be for supervised learning
into a continuous variable number. So another
way to say it is predict this variable in the
future. So the future is just means like that
continuous variable doesn't have to be time. But
that's just a good example of regression. So what
will the temperature be next week? So we will be
20? Celsius? How would we determine that? Well, we
would have vectors, so dots, they're plotted on a
graph that has multiple dimensions, the dimensions
could be greater than just x and y, you could have
many. And then you have a regression line. This
is the line that's going through our data set.
And and that's going to help us figure out how to
predict the value. So how would we do that? Well,
we we need to calculate the distance of a
vector from the regression line, which is
called an error. And so different regression
algorithms use the error to predict different
variable a future variable. So just to look at
this graphic here, so here's our regression line.
And here is a dot like a vector or a piece
of information. And this distance from the
line that the actual distance is what we're
going to use in our ML model to figure out
if we were to plot another line up here,
right? You know, we compare this line to
all the other lines, okay? And that's how we find
similarity. And what will commonly see for this
is mean squared error, root mean squared error,
mean? absolute error. So MSE, mrsc, and Ma. Okay.
Let's take a closer look at the concepts
of classification. So classification is the
process of finding a function to divide a labeled
data set. So again, this is supervised learning
into classes or categories, so predict a category
to apply to the inputted data. So will it rain
next Saturday, will it be sunny or rainy? So we
have our data set. And the idea is we're drawing
through this a classification line to divide the
data set. So regression we're measuring the line
to or the vectors to the line. And this line is
just what side of the line is that on? If it's on
this side, then it's sunny. If it's on this side,
it's rainy. Okay. For classification algorithms,
we got large logistic regression decision
trees, random forests, neural networks,
Naive Bayes, k nearest neighbor, also known as k
and n, and support vector machines. svms. Okay.
Let's take a closer look at clustering.
So clustering is the process of grouping
unlabeled data. So unlabeled data means it's
unsupervised learning based on similarities
and differences. So the outcome could be grouped
data based on similarities or differences. I guess
it's the same description up here. But imagine
we have a graph and we have data. And the idea
is we draw boundaries around that to see similar
groups. So maybe we're recommending purchases to
Windows computers, or recommending purchase to Mac
computers. Now remember, this is unlabeled data,
so the label is being inferred, or, or
they're just saying these things are similar,
right? So clustering algorithms, we got k means
K, mi dois, identity base hierarchial. Okay.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we're looking at the confusion matrix. And this
is a table to visualize the mall predictions,
the predicted versus the ground truth labels,
the actual also known as that error matrix,
and they're useful for classification problems
to determine if our, if our classification is
working as we think it is. So imagine we have
a question how many bananas did this person eat
or these people eat? And so we have this kind of
box here where we have predicted versus actual,
and it's really comparing the ground truth,
and what the model predicted, right? And so on the
exam, they'll ask you questions like, Okay, well
imagine that. And they might not even say yes or
no, maybe like zero and one. And so what they're
saying is, you know, imagine you have, you want to
tell us the true positives, right? And so the idea
is, they won't show you the labels here, but you
know, one in one would be a true positive and zero
and zero would be a false negative. Okay? Another
thing they'll ask you about these confusion matrix
is, is the size of them. So the idea is that we're
looking right now at a oops, just gonna erase that
there. But we're looking at a binary classifier
because we have one label and just two labels,
right, one and two, okay, but we you could have
three say one, two, and three. So how would you
calculate that well, Be a third cell over here you
know and so it's gonna be an excellent predictive
because we're only gonna have ground truth
versus prediction. And so that's how you'll
know it will be six the size will be six might
not say cells, but we'll just say six. Okay.
So to understand anomaly detection, let's define
quickly what is an anomaly so an abnormal thing
that is marked by deviation from the norm or
standard. So, anomaly detection is the process of
finding outliers within a data set color anomaly
so detecting when a piece of data or access
patterns appear suspicious or malicious. So use
cases for anomaly detection can be data cleaning,
intrusion detection, fraud detection, system
health monitoring, event detection and sensory
or sensor networks, ecosystem disturbances,
detection of critical and cascading flaws,
anomaly detection is by hand is a very tedious
process of using ml for a knowledge section is
more efficient and accurate. And Azure
has a service called anomaly detector
detects anomalies in data to quickly find,
quickly identify and troubleshoot issues.
So computer vision is when we use machine
learning neural networks to gain high level
understanding of digital images or videos. So for
computer vision deep learning algorithms, we have
convolution neural networks. These are for image
and video recognition. They're inspired after how
the human eye actually processes information, and
sends it back to the brain to be processed. You
have recurrent neural networks RNNs, which are
generally used for handwriting recognition or
speech recognition. Of course, these algorithms
have other applications, but these are the most
common use cases for them. four types of
computer vision, we have image classification,
so look at an image or video and classify its
place in a category object detection. So identify
objects within an image or video and apply labels
and location boundaries. semantic segmentation,
so identify segments or objects by drawing
pixel masks around them so great for objects
and movement, image analysis, so analyze an
image or video to apply descriptive context
labels. So maybe an employee is sitting at a desk
in Tokyo would be something that image analysis
would do optical character recognition, or OCR,
find text in images or videos and extract them
into digital text for editing facial detection,
so detect faces in a photo or video, and dry
location boundary and label their expression. So
for computer vision to some things around Azure
Microsoft services, there's one called seeing
AI. It's an app developed by Microsoft for iOS.
So you use your device camera to identify
objects, people and objects, and the app is
audibly describes those objects for people with
visual impairments. It's totally free. If you
have an iOS app, I have an Android phone so I
cannot use it. But I hear it's great. Some of
the Azure computer vision service offerings is
computer vision. So analyze images and videos,
extract descriptions, tags, objects and texts,
custom vision so custom image classification
object detection models using your own images
face so detect and identify people and emotions
and images form recognizer, so translate scan
documents into key value or tabular editable data.
So natural language processing, also known as
NLP is machine learning that can understand the
context of a corpus corpus being a body
of related text. So NLP is enable you
to analyze and interpret text within documents
and email messages interpret, or contextualize
spoken tokens. So for example, maybe customer
sentiment analysis whether customers happy or sad,
synthesize speech, so a voice
assistants assistant talking to you
automatically translate spoken or written
phrases and sentences between languages,
interpret spoken or written commands and determine
appropriate actions. A very famous example for a
voice assistant specifically or virtual assistant
for Microsoft is Cortana. He uses the Bing
search engine to perform tasks such as setting
reminders and answering questions for the user.
And if you're on a Windows 10 machine, it's
very easy to activate Cortana by accident.
When we were talking about Azure as MLP offering
we have text an analytic so sentiment analysis to
find out what customers think. Find topic. Topic
relevant phrases using key phrase extraction,
identify the language of the text with language
detection, detect and categorize entities in your
text. With named entity recognition for translator
we have real time text translation and multi
language support. For speech service. We
have transcribe audible speech into readable
searchable text, and then we have language
understand understanding, also known as Louis
natural language processing service that enables
you to understand human language in your own
application website, chatbots IoT device and
more when we talk about conversational AI,
it usually generally uses NLP so that's
where you'll see that overlap next, okay.
Let's take a look here at conversational AI,
which is technology that can participate in
conversations with humans. So we have chatbots
voice assistant In an interactive voice
recognition systems, which is like the second
version to interactive voice response system,
so you know, when you call in and they say
press these numbers that is a response to some
and recognition system is when they can actually
take human speech and translate that into action.
So the use cases here would be online customer
support replaces human agents for, for replying
about customer FAQs, maybe shipping questions
anything about customer support, accessibility, so
voice opera UI for those who are visually impaired
HR processes, so employee training, onboarding,
updating employee information. I've never seen it
used like that. But that's what they say is the
use case healthcare accessible, affordable health
care. So maybe you're doing a claim process. I've
never seen this. But maybe in the US where you do
more your claims and everything is privatized, it
makes more sense, Internet of Things, IoT devices.
So Amazon, Alexa Apple, Siri, Google Home,
and I suppose Cortana, but it doesn't really have
a particular device. So that's why I didn't list
it their computer software, so autocomplete
search on phone or desktop. So that would be
Cortana. Something it could do. For the two
services that around conversational AI for Azure,
we have q&a maker so create a conversational
Question and Answer bot from your existing
content, also known as a knowledge base,
and Azure bot service intelligent service
bot service that scales on demand used
for creating publishing managing bots. So
the idea is you make your bot here and
then you deploy it with this. Okay.
Let's take a look here at responsible AI which
focuses on ethical, transparent and accountable
uses ai ai technology, Microsoft puts into
practice responsible AI via its six Microsoft
AI principles. This whole thing is invented by
Microsoft. And so you know, it's not necessarily
a standard but it's something that Microsoft
is pushing hard to have people adopt Okay,
so we The first thing we have is fairness.
So this is an AI system, which should treat
all people fairly, we have reliability and
safety and AI systems should perform reliably
and safely. Privacy and Security AI system should
be secure and respect privacy inclusiveness
system should empower everyone and engage people
transparency, AI systems should be understandable
accountability. People should be accountable
for AI systems and we need to know these in
greater detail. So we're going to have a
short little video on each of these okay.
First arlis is fairness. So AI systems should
treat all people fairly so an AI system can
reinforce existing social societal stereotype,
stereotypical bias can be introduced during the
development of a pipeline. So an AI system that
are used to allocate or withhold opportunities,
resources or information in domains such as
criminal justice, employee employment in hiring,
finance, and credit. So an example here would be
an ml model designed to select a final applicant
for hiring pipeline without incorporating any
bias based on gender, ethnicity or may result
in unfair advantage. So as your ml can tell you
how each feature can influence a models prediction
for bias. One thing that could be of use is fair
learn. So it's an open source Python project to
help data scientists to improve fairness and the
AI systems. At the time of I made this course,
a lot of their stuff is still in preview. So
you know, it's the fairness component is it's
not 100% there, but it's great to see
that they're getting that along. Okay.
So we are on to our second AI principle for
Microsoft and this one is AI systems should
perform reliably and safely. So AI software
must be rigorously tested to ensure they work
as expected before released to the end user. If
there are scenarios where AI is making mistakes,
it is important to release a report quantified
risks and harms to end users so they are
informed of the shortcomings of an AI solution.
Something you should really remember for the exam,
they'll definitely ask that AI were concern
for reliability, safety for humans is
critically important. autonomous vehicles,
health diagnosis, suggestions, prescriptions
and autonomous weapon systems. They didn't
mention this in their content. And I was just like
doing some additional resource research. I'm like,
yeah, you really don't want mistakes when you have
automated weapons or ethical You shouldn't have
them at all. But hey, that's, that's just how the
world works. But yeah, this is this category here.
We're on to our third Microsoft AI
principle AI system should be secure and
respect privacy. So AI can require vast
amounts of data to train deep machine ml
models, the nature of an ml model may require
personally identifiable information. So P eyes,
it is important that we ensure protection of user
data that is not leak or disclosed. In some cases,
ml models can be run locally on a user's device.
So their PII is remain on their device avoiding
the vulnerability. This is called this is like
edge computing. So that's the concept there
AI security principles to check malicious actors.
So data origin and lineage data use internal
versus external data corruption considerations,
anomaly detection. So there you go.
We're on to the fourth Microsoft principles of
assets. Should empower everyone and engage people.
If we can design AI solutions for the minority
of users, they can design AI solutions to the
majority of users. So we're talking about minority
groups, we're talking about physical ability,
gender, sexual orientation, ethnicity,
other factors. This one's really simple.
In terms of practicality, it doesn't 100%
make sense, because if you've worked with
groups that are deaf and blind developing
technology for them, a lot of times they need
specialized solutions. But the approach here is
that, you know, if we can design for the minority,
we can design for all that is the principle
there. So that's what we need to know. Okay.
Let's take a look here at transparency.
So AI system should be understandable. So
interpretability, and intelligibility is when the
end user can understand the behavior of UI. So
transparency of AI systems can
result in mitigating unfairness
help developers debug their AI systems
gaining more trust from our users,
those builds a, those who build AI systems should
be open about why they're using AI open about the
limitations of the AI systems. adopting an open
source AI framework can provide transparency,
at least from a technical perspective on
the internal workings of an AI system.
We are on to the last Microsoft AI principle
here people should be accountable for AI
systems. So the structure put in place to
consistently enacting AI principles and
taking them into account AI systems should work
within frameworks of governments, organizational
principles, ethical and legal standards that
are clearly defined principles guide Microsoft
and how they develop, sell an advocate when
working with third parties and this push
towards regulation towards a principle. So
this is Microsoft saying, Hey, everybody adopt
our model. There are many other models, I guess
it's great that Microsoft is taking the charge
there, I just feel that it needs to be a bit
more well developed. But what we'll do is look
at some more practical examples so we can better
understand how to apply their principles. Okay.
So if we really want to understand how
to apply the Microsoft AI principles,
they've great created this nice little tool via a
free web app for practical scenarios. So they have
these cards, you can read through these cards,
they're color coded for different scenarios,
and there's a website so let's go take a
look at that and see what we can learn Okay.
All right, so we're here on the guidelines
for human AI interaction so we can better
understand the how to put into
practice the Microsoft AI principles.
They have 18 cards and let's work our way through
here and see the examples the first one our list,
make clear what the system can do help the users
understand what the AI system is capable of doing.
So here PowerPoint quickstart builders and
builds an online outline to help you get started
researching subject displays suggested topics
that help you understand the features capability.
Then we have the Bing app shows examples
of types of things you can search for.
Apple Watch displays all metrics attracts
explains how going on the second card we
have make clear how well the system can do
what it can do. So here we have office new
companion experience ideas doc alongside your
work, and offers one click assistance but
grammar design data insights, richer images
and more. The unassuming term ideas coupled
with label previews, help set expectations
and presented suggestions. The recommender
in Apple Music uses language such as we will
think you'll like to communicate uncertainty.
The Help page for Outlook webmail explains
the filtering into focused and other
and we'll start working right away but we'll
get better with use, making clear the mistakes
will happen and you teach the product and
set overrides onto our red cards. Here.
We have time surfaces based on context
time when to act or interrupt based
on the user's current task environment.
When it's time to leave for appointments,
Outlook sends a time to leave notification
with directions for both driving and public
transit taking into account current location
of that location real time traffic information.
And then we have after using Apple Maps routing,
it remembers when you're parked your car when you
open the app after a little while it suggests
routing to the location of the parked car.
All these Apple examples make me think that
Microsoft has some kind of partnership with Apple.
I guess I guess Microsoft or or Bill Gates did
own Apple shares. So maybe they're closer than
we think, show contextually relevant information
time when to act or interrupt based on user's
current task and environment. Powered by
machine learning acronyms in Word helps you
understand shorthand employed in your own work
environment relative to current OpenDocument.
On walmart.com, when the user is looking at
a product, such as gaming console recommends
accessories and games that would go with
it. When a user searches for movies, Google
shows results including showtimes near
the user's location for the current data
onto our fifth card here. Match based.
We didn't we didn't miss this one, right.
Yeah, we did. Okay, so we're on the fifth one here
match relevant social norms ensure experiences
delivered in a way that users would expect Given
the social cultural context when editor identifies
ways to improve writing style prints optionals
politely consider using. That's the Canadian way
being polite. Google Photos is able to recognize
pets and use the wording important cats and dogs
recognizing that for many pets are an important
part of one's family. And you know what? When I
started renting my new house, I said, you know,
these are probably dogs and my landlord said,
Well, of course pets are part of the
family. That was something I like to hear.
Cortana uses semi formal town apologizing when
unable to find a contact, which is polite and
socially appropriate. I like that. Okay,
mitigate social biases ensure AI system,
languages and behaviors do not reinforce
undesirable unfair stereotypes and biases.
My analytics summarizes how you spend your time at
work, and suggest ways to work smarter one ways to
mitigate bias is by using gender neutral icons
to represent important people sounds good to me.
A Bing search for SEO or doctor shows images of
diverse people in terms of gender and ethnicity.
Sounds good to me. The predictive keyboard for
Android suggests both genders when typing a
pronoun starting with the letter H. We're onto our
yellow cards support efficient invocation so make
it easy to invoke or request system services
when needed. So Flash Fill is a helpful time
saver in Excel that can be easily invoked with on
canvas interactions and that keep you in flow on
amazon.com Oh, hey there got Amazon. In addition
to the system giving recommendations as you Rouse
you can manually invoke additional recommendations
from the recommender for your menu. design ideas
in Microsoft PowerPoint can be invoked with the
with the press of a button if needed. I cannot
stand it when that pops up. He's up to tell it to
leave me alone. Okay, support efficient, dismal,
efficient. Does Mazal dismissal Oh, support
efficient dismissal? Okay, make it easy to dismiss
or ignore under undesired AI system services.
Okay, that sounds good to me. Microsoft forms
allows you to create custom surveys, quizzes,
polls, questionnaires and forms some choices,
questions triggers suggested options, but just
beneath the relevant question, this suggestion can
be easily ignored and dismissed. Instagram allows
the user to easily hide report ads that have been
suggested by AI by tapping the ellipses
at the top of the right of the ad.
Siri can be easily dismissed by saying Never
mind. always telling my Alexa Nevermind. Support
efficient correction make it easy to edit, refine
or recover the AI system when the when the AI
system is wrong, so I'll Auto altex automatically
generates alt text for photographs by using
intelligence services in the cloud descriptions
can be easily modified by clicking the alt text
button in the ribbon once you set a reminder,
with Siri, the UI displays a tap to edit link.
When being automatically correct spelling errors
in search queries it provides the option to revert
to the query as originally typed with one click
onto a card number 10. Scope services when in
doubt, engage in dis ambiguous, Anubis, disk
and big uation or gracefully degrade the AI
system service when uncertain about a user's
goal. So an auto replacement word is uncertain
of a correction it engages in disambiguation by
displaying multiple options you can select from
certain will let you know it has trouble hearing
if you don't respond or talk or, or speak too
softly. Bing Maps will provide multiple routing
options when, when unable to recommend best one
we're onto card number 11. make clear why the
system did what it did enable users to access
an explanation of why the AI system behaved as it
did. Office Online recommends document documents
based on history and activity descriptive text
above each document makes it clear why the
recommendation is shown. product recommendations
on amazon.com include why recommend recommended
link that shows that what products in the user
shopping history and forums. The recommendations
Facebook enables you to access an explanation
about why you are seeing each ad in the news feed
onto our green cards. So remember recent
interactions so maintain short term memory
and allow the user to make efficient references
to that memory. When attaching a file outlook
offers a list of recent files including recently
copied file links. Look also remembers people
you have interacted with recently and
displays them when addressing a new email
being searched remember, some recent queries and
search can be continued. conversationally. How
old is he after a search for Keanu Reeves? Siri
carries over the contacts from one interaction to
the next a text message is created from the person
you told Siri to message to onto card number 13
lucky number 13 learn from user behavior personal
user experience by learning from their actions
over time. Tap on the search bar in Office
applications and search lists the top three
commands on your screen that you're most likely
to need to personalize the technology called
zero query doesn't even need to type in the search
bar to provide a personalized predictive answer.
amazon.com gives personalized product
recommendations recommendations based on previous
purchases on the card 14. update and adapt
cautiously limit disruptive changes when updating
adaptive adapting the AI systems behaviors so
PowerPoint designer improves slides for office
365 subscribers by automatically generating design
ideas from to choose from designer has integrated
new capabilities such as smart graphics, icons,
suggestions and existing user experience ensuring
the updates are not disruptive. Office tell office
Tell me feature shows dynamically recommended
items and it doesn't need a try area to minimize
disruptive changes onto card number 15. Encouraged
granular feedback enabled users to provide
feedback indicating their preferences during
regular interactions with the AI system so
ideas in Excel empowers you to understand
your data through high level visual summaries,
trends and patterns encourages feedback on each
suggestion by asking is this helpful? Not only
does Instagram provide the option to hide specific
ads, but it's also solicits feedback to
understand why the ad is not relevant.
In Apple's music app love dislike buttons are
prominent, easily accessible. Number 16 convey
the consequences of user actions immediately
under update or convey how user actions will
impact future behaviors of the AI system. You can
get stock and geographic data types in Excel It is
easy as typing text into a cell and converting
it to stock data type or geographic geographic
data type. When you perform the conversion action,
an icon immediately appears in the converted cells
upon tapping the like Dislike button for each
recommendation. In Apple Music, a pop up informs
the user that they'll receive more or fewer
similar recommendations onto card number 17.
Or almost near the end provide global controls
allow the user to globally customize the system.
System monitors and how it behaves so editor
expands on spelling and grammar. Checking
capabilities of words include more advanced
proofing and editing designed to ensure document
is readable editor can flag a range of critique
types and allow to customize the thing is is that
in Word, it's so awful spell checking, I don't
understand like it's been years and the spell
checking never gets better. So the guy implore
better spell checking. I think being search
provides settings that impact that the types
of results the engine will return, for example,
safe search. Then we have Google Photos allows you
to to turn location history on and off for future
photos. It's kind of funny seeing like being in
there about like using AI because at one point,
it's almost pretty certain that Bing was copying
just google search indexes to learn how to index.
I don't know that's Microsoft for you. We're
onto card 18 notify users about changes
informed user when AI system adds or updates as
capabilities. Then what's new dialog in office
informs you about changes by giving an overview
of the latest features and updates, including
updates to AI features in Outlook web to help
tab includes a what's new section that covers
updates. So there we go. We made it to
the end of the list. I hope that was a
fun lesson for you. And there I hope that we
could kind of match up the the responsibly
I I kind of wish what they would have done is
actually mapped it out here and say word match,
but I guess it's kind of an isolate service that
kind of ties in. So I guess there we go, Okay.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro. And we're looking at
Azure cognitive services. And this is
a comprehensive family of AI services,
and cognitive API's to help you build
intelligent apps. So create customizable,
pre trained models built with breakthrough AI
researchers I put that in quotations I'm kind
of throwing some shade at Microsoft Azure just
because it's their marketing material, right?
deploy Cognitive Services anywhere from cloud to
the edge. With containers get started quickly no
machine learning expertise required. But I think
it helps to have a bit of background knowledge
developed with strict ethical standards. Microsoft
loves talking about the responsible. There's
responsible AI stuff, empowering responsible use
with industry leading tools and guidelines. So
let's do a quick breakdown of the types of
services in this family. So for decision we have
anomaly detector identify potential problems early
on content moderator detect potentially offensive
or unwanted content, personalize or create
rich personalized experiences for every user.
For languages we have language understanding, also
known as alue is Louis I don't know I didn't put
the initialism there but don't worry, we'll see it
again. Build natural language understanding into
app spots and IoT devices q&a maker create
a conversational Question and Answer layer
over your data text analytics. detect sentiment.
So sentiment is like whether customers are happy,
sad, glad, keep phrases and named entities
translator detect and translate more than
90 supported languages. For speech, we have
speech to text to transcribe audible speech
into readable search text, text to speech convert
text to lifelike speech for natural interfaces,
speech translation, so integrate real time speech
translation into your apps, Speaker recognition,
identify and verify the people speaking based
on audio for vision. We have computer vision,
so analyze content and images and videos
custom vision, so analyze or sorry,
customize image record or image
recognition to fit your business needs,
face detect and identify people and
emotions in images. So there you go.
So as your cognitive services is an umbrella
AI service that enables customers to access
multiple AI services with an API key and API
endpoint, so what you do is you go create a
new cognitive service. And once you're there,
it's going to generate two keys and an endpoint.
And that is what you're using generally for
authentication with the various AI services
programmatically. And that is something that
is key to the service that you need to know.
So knowledge mining is a discipline in AI that
uses a combination of intelligence services to
quickly learn from vast amounts of information.
So it allows organizations to deeply understand
and easily explore information, uncover hidden
insights and find relationships and patterns
at scale. So we have ingest, enrich and explore
as our three steps. So for ingest content from
a range of sources using connectors to first
and third party data stores. So we might have
structured data such as databases csvs.
The csvs would more be semi structured,
but we're not going to get into that level
of detail unstructured data. So PDFs, videos,
images and audio for enrich the content with AI
capabilities that let you extract information,
find patterns and deepen understanding. So
cognitive services like vision, language, speech,
decision, and search, and explore the newly
indexed data via search bots, existing businesses,
applications and data visualizations and rich,
structured data, customer relationship management,
rap systems, Power BI, this whole knowledge mining
thing is a thing but like, I believe that the
whole model around this is so that Azure shows you
how you can use the cognitive services to solve
things without having to invent new solutions. So
let's look at a bunch of use cases that Azure has
and see what where we can find some useful use.
So the first one here is for content research. So
when organizations task employees review and
research of technical data, it can be tedious
to read page after page of dense Tex knowledge
mining helps employees quickly review these dense
materials. So you have a document and in the
Richmond step, you could be doing printed text
recognition key phrase extraction, sharpen or
sharpen skills, technical keyword, sanitation,
format, definition minor large scale vocabulary
matcher, you put it through a search service,
and now you have search reference library,
so it makes things a lot easier to work with.
Now, we have audit risk compliance management
so developers could use knowledge mining to help
attorneys quickly identify entities of importance
from discovery documents and flag important ideas
across documents that we have documents. So clause
extraction clause classification, TV power risk,
named identity extraction, key phrase extraction,
language detection, automate translation, then you
put it back into a search index and now you can
use it our management platform or a word plug
in. And so we have business process management in
industries where bidding competition is fierce, or
when the diagnosis of a problem must be quick or
in near real time, companies use knowledge mining
to avoid costly mistakes. So the client drilling
and completion reports, document processor,
ai services and custom models queue for human
validation, Intelligent Automation, you send it
to a back end system or a data lake and or a data
lake and then you do your analytics dashboard.
Then we have customer support and feedback
analysis. So for many companies, customer support
is costly and efficient. Knowledge mining can
help customer support teams quickly find the right
answers for a customer inquiry or assess customer
sentiment at scale. So you have your source data,
you do your document cracking use cognitive
skills, so pre trained services or custom.
You have enriched documents. From here you're
going to do your projections and have a knowledge
store you're gonna have a search index, and
then do your analytics something like Power BI,
we have digital assessment management. There's a
lot of these but it really helps you understand
how cognitive services are going to be useful.
Given the amount of unstructured data created
daily, many companies are struggling to make
use of or find information within their files.
Knowledge mining through a search index
makes it easy for end customers and
employees to locate what they're looking
for faster. So you can just like art,
metadata and the actual images themselves for
the top player. geopoint extractor biographical
richer than down below we're tagging, we're
custom object detector similar image tagger,
we put it in a search index, they love those
search indexes. And now you have an art Explorer.
We have contract management, this is the
last one here, many companies create products
for multiple sectors. Hence the business
opportunities with different vendors and
buyers increase exponentially. Knowledge mining
can help organizations to scour 1000s of pages of
sources to create Accurate Bids. So here we have
RFP documents. This will actually probably come
back later in the original set, but we will will
will do risk extraction, print text recognition,
key phrase extraction, organizational
extraction engineering standards
will create a search index and put it
here, this will bring back data. Also,
metadata extraction will come back here. And then
this is just like a continuous pipeline, okay.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we are looking at face service. And Azure face
service provides an AI algorithm that can detect
recognize and analyze human faces and images,
such as a face and an image face with specific
attributes, face landmarks similar faces the same
face as a specific identity across a gallery
of images. So here's an example of an image
that I ran that will do in the follow along.
And what it's done is it's drawn a bounding
box around the image. And there's this ID and
this is a unique identifier, string for each
detected face in an image. And these can be unique
across a gallery, which is really useful as well.
Another cool thing you can do is face landmarks.
So the idea is that you have a face and it can
identify very particular components of it. And
up to 27 predefined landmarks is what is provided
with this face service. Another interesting thing
is face attributes. So you can check whether
they're wearing accessories, accessories, so think
like earrings or lip rings, determine its age,
the blurriness of the image, what kind of emotion
is being experienced the exposure of the image,
you know, the contrast, facial hair, gender,
glasses, your hair in general, the head pose,
there's a lot of information around that makeup,
which seems to be limited, like when we ran it
here in the lab, all we got back was eye makeup
and lip makeup. But hey, we get some information,
whether they're wearing a mask, noise, so
whether there's artifacts like visual artifacts,
or occlusion, so whether an object is blocking
the parts of the face, and then they simply have
a boolean value for whether the person smiling or
not, which I assume is a very common component.
So that's pretty much all we really need to
know about the face service. And there you go.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam prep, and we
are looking at the speech and translate service.
So Azure is translate service is a translation
services the name implies, and it can translate 90
languages and dialects. And I was even surprised
to find out that it can translate into calling on
and it uses neural machine translation and Mt
replacing its legacy to statistical machine
translation SMT. So what my guess here is that
statistical meaning that it used classical
machine learning back in 2010, and, and then they
decided to switch it over to neural networks,
which, of course, would be a lot more accurate
as your transit service can support a custom
translator. So it allows you to extend the service
for translation based on your business domain use
cases. So if you use a lot of technical words and
things like that, then you can fine tune that or
particular phrases. Then there's the other
service, Azure speech service. And this is a,
a speech, synthesis service, a service. So
what can do speech to text text to speech
and speech translation, so it's
synthesizing creating new voices. Okay,
so we have speech to text. So real time speech
to text batch batching multidevice, conversation,
conversation, transcription. And you can create
custom speech models and you have text to speech.
So this utilizes a speech synthesis markup
language, so it's just a way of formatting it,
and it can create custom voices. Then you have
the voice assistance of integrates with the Bot
Framework SDK, and speech recognition. So speaker
verification and identification. So there you go.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro.
And we were looking at text analytics and
this is a service for NLP so natural language
processing for text mining and text analysis. So
text analytics can perform sentiment analysis,
so find out what people think about your brand
or topics. So features provide sentiment
labels, such as negative, neutral positive,
then you have opinion mining, which is an
aspect based sentiment analysis. It's for
granular information about the opinions related
to aspects. Then you have key phrase extraction.
So quickly identify the main concepts in text.
You have language detections that detect the
language of an input, a text that it's written
in, and you have named entity recognition,
so ner so identify and categorize entities in your
text as people places off objects and quantities,
and subset of any AR is personally identifiable
information. So P eyes, let's just look at a few
of these more in detail. Some of them are very
obvious, but some of these would help to have
an example. So the first we're looking at is key
phrase extraction. So quickly identify the main
concepts in text. So key phrase extraction works
best when you when you give bigger amounts of
text to work on. This is the opposite of sentiment
analysis, which performs better on smaller amounts
of text. So document sizes can be 5000 or fewer
characters per document. And you can have up to
1000 items per collection. So imagine you have a
movie review with a lot of text in here and you
want to extract out the key phrases. So here it
is, sideboard ship, enterprise, surface travels,
things like that, then you have named entity
recognition. So this detects words and phrases
mentioned in unstructured data that can be
associated with one or more semantic types. And
so here's an example. I think this is medicine,
bass. And so the idea is that it's identifying,
it's identifying these words or phrases, and then
it's applying a semantic type. So it's saying like
this is like diagnosis is the medication class
and stuff like that. semantic type could be more
broad. So there's location events, a habit
location, twice here, person diagnosis age,
and there is a predefined set, I believe that is
in Azure that you should expect, but they have
a generic one. And then there's one that's for
health. We're looking at sentiment analysis, this
graphic makes it make a lot more sense when we're
splitting between sentiment and opinion mining.
The idea here is that sentiment analysis will
apply labels and confidence scores to text at
the sentence and document level. And so labels
could include negative positive, mixed or neutral
and will have a confidence score ranging from
zero to one. And so over here, we have a sentiment
analysis of this line here and in saying that
this was a negative sentiment. But look, there's
something that's positive and there's something
that's negative, so was it really negative,
and that's where opinion mining gets really
useful because it has more granular data,
where we have a subject and we have an opinion,
right and so here we can see the room was great,
but the staff was unfriendly negative.
So we have a bit of a split there Okay.
Hey, this is Angie brown from exam pro and we
are looking at optical character recognition,
also known as OCR, and this is the process of
extracting printed or handwritten text into a
digital and editable format. So OCR can be applied
to photos of street signs, products, documents,
invoices, bills, financial reports, articles and
more. And so here's an example of us extracting
out nutritional data or nutritional facts off the
back of a food product. So Azure has two different
kinds of API's that can perform OCR. They have the
OCR API and the read API. So the OCR API uses an
older recognition model. It supports only images,
it executes synchronous notes synchronously,
returning immediately, when it detects texts, it's
suited for less text, it supports more languages,
it's easier to implement. And on the other
side, we have the read API. So this is an
updated recognition model supports images
and PDFs, executes asynchronously. paralyzes
tasks per line for faster results, suited
for lots of tax supports a few languages,
and it's a bit more difficult to implement.
And so when we want to use this service,
we're going to be using computer vision SDK,
okay. Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro,
and we're taking a look here at form recognizer
service. This is a specialized OCR service that
translates printed text into digital and editable
content. It pervert preserves the structure and
relationships of the form like data. That's what
makes it so special. So form recognizer is used
to automate data entry in your applications
and enrich your document search capabilities.
It can identify key value pairs selection marks
table structures, it can produce output structures
such as original file relationships, bounding
boxes, confidence score, and form recognizer is
composed of a custom document processing models,
pre built models for invoices, receipts, IDs,
business cards, the model layouts, let's talk
about the layout here. So extract text selection
marks table structures along with bounding box
coordinates from documents form. recognizer can
extract text selection marks and table structures.
The row and column numbers associate with the text
using high definition optical character
enhancement models. That is totally useless text.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And we
are looking at form recognizers service. And this
is a specialized service for OCR. That translates
printed text into digital editable content.
But the magic here is that that preserves the
structure and relationship of form like data. So
there's an invoice you see those magenta lines,
it's saying identify that form like data. So
for recognizer is used to automate data entry
in your applications and enrich your document
search capabilities. And it can identify key value
pairs, selection of marks, tables, structures,
and it can put structures such as original file
relationships, bounding box boxes, confidence
scores. It's composed of customer custom document
processing model, pre built models for invoices,
receipts, IDs, business cards, it's based
on this layout model. And there you go.
So let's touch upon custom models. So custom
models allow you to extract text key value
pairs selection marks in tabular data from your
forms. These models are trained with your data,
so they're tailored to your
forms, you only need five samples,
sample input forms to start, a trained document
processing model can output structured data that
includes the relationship and the original
form document. After you train the model,
you can test and retrain it and eventually
use it reliably extract data from
more forms according to your needs. You have two
learning options, you have unsupervised learning
to understand the layout and relationships
between fields entries in your forms. And
you have supervised learning to extract values of
interest using the labeled form. So we've covered
unsupervised and supervised learning, so you're
going to be very familiar with these two. Okay.
So form recognizer service has many pre built
models that are easy to get started with. And
so let's go look at them and see what kind
of fields that extracts out by default.
So the first is receipts. So sales receipts
from Australia, Canada, Great Britain,
India and United States will work great here and
the fields that will extract out his receipt type
merchant name, merchant phone number, merchant
address, transaction, date, transaction time,
total subtotal, tax tip, items, name, quantity,
price, total price, there's information that is on
a receipt that you're not getting out of
these fields. And that's where you make
your own custom model right. For Business cards.
It's only available for English business cards,
but we can extract our contact names first name,
last name, company names, departments, job titles,
emails, websites, addresses, mobile phones,
faxes, work phones, and other phone numbers.
Not sure how many people are using business cards
these days, but hey, they have it as an option
for invoices, extract data from invoices in
various formats and return structured data.
So we have customer name, customer ID,
purchase order, invoice, ID, invoice, date,
due date, vendor name, vendor address,
vendor address, receipt, customer address,
customer address, receipt and billing address,
billing address, receipt shipping address,
subtotal, total tax invoice,
total amount to service address,
remittance address, start service start date
and end date, previous unpaid balance and then
they even have one for line items. So items amount
description, quantity, unit price, Product Code,
unit date, tax, and then for IDs which could be
worldwide passports, US driver's license, things
like that. You have fields such as country region,
date of birth, date of expiry expiration document
name, first name, last name, nationality, sex,
machine readable zone, I'm not sure what that is
document type, and address and region. And
there are some additional features with some
of these bottles. We didn't really cover them
it's not that important but yeah, there we go.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro, and we're
looking at natural understanding or Lewis or Luis
depends on how you'd like to say it. And this
is a no code ml service to build language,
natural language into apps, bots and IoT devices
have quickly create enterprise ready custom models
that continuously improve so Louis I'm gonna
just call it Louis because that's what I prefer
is access via its own isolate domain@lewis.ai
at a utilizes NLP and NLU so NLU is the ability
to perform or ability to transform a linguistic
statement to a representation that enables you
to understand your users naturally. And it is
intended to focus on intention and extraction,
okay, so where the users want, or was or what the
users want, and what the users are talking about.
So the loose application is composed of a schema
and a schema is auto generated for you when you
use the Louis AI web interface. So you definitely
are going to be reading this by hand, but it just
helps to see what's kind of in there. If you do
have some programmatic skills, you obviously you
can make better use of the service isn't just the
web interface. But the schema defines intention.
So what the users are asking for a loose app
always contains a nun intent. We'll talk about
why that is in a moment. And entities what parts
of the intent is used to determine the answer.
Then you also have utterances. So examples of the
user input that includes intent and entities to
train the ML model to match predictions against
the real user input. So an intent requires one
or more example utterance for training. And it is
recommended to have 15 to 30 example utterances
to explicitly train to ignore an utterance
you use the nun intent. So, intent
classifies that user as utterances and entities
extract data from utterances. So hopefully it
understands I always get this stuff mixed up, it
always takes me a bit of time to understand there
is more than just these things is like features
and other things. But you know, for the 900, we
don't need to go that deep. Okay, just to skip to
visualizing this to make a bit easier. So imagine
we have this, this utterance here, these would
be the identities that we have to end Toronto,
this is example utterance. And then the idea is
that you'd have the intent and the intent. And if
you look at this keyword here, this really helps
Word says classify is that's what it is. It's
a classification of this example utterance, and
that's how the ML model is going to learn, okay.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam prep, and
we're looking at q&a maker service. And this is a
cloud based NLP service that allows you to create
a natural conversational layer over your data.
So q&a maker is hosted on its own iyslah
domain at q&a maker.ai it will help the most,
it will help you find the most appropriate
answer from any input from your custom knowledge
base of information. So you can commonly it's
commonly used to build conversation clients,
which includes social apps chatbots speech enabled
desktop applications. q&a maker doesn't store
customer data, all the customer data stored in
the region, the customer deploys the dependent
services instances within Okay, so let's look at
some of the use cases for this. So when you have
static information, you can use q&a maker in your
knowledge base. The answers this knowledge base is
custom to your needs, which you've built with
documents such as PDF URLs, where you want to
provide the same answer to repeat question command
when different users submit the same question the
answers is returned when you want to filter stack
information based on meta information. So meta tag
data is provide provides additional filtering
options relevant to your client application
users and information common metadata information
includes chitchat content type, format, content,
purpose, content, freshness. And there's the use
case when you want to manage a bot conversation
that includes static information. So your
knowledge base takes takes the user conversational
text, or command and answers that if the answer
is part of a pre determined conversation flow,
represented in the knowledge base with multiple
turnkey contexts the bot can easily provide this
flow. So q&a maker import your content into a
knowledge base of questions and answer pairs.
And q&a maker can build your knowledge base
from an existing document manual, or website,
your all docx PDF. I thought this was the coolest
thing. So you can just basically have anyone write
a docx. As long as it has a heading and a text.
They can even extract images and I'll just turn it
into the bot. It just saves you so much time It's
crazy. It will use ml to extract the question and
answer pairs. The content of the question and
answer pairs include all the alternate forms
of the question metadata tags used to filter
choices. During the search, follow up prompts
to continue to search refinement, refinement,
q&a maker stores, answers text in markdown.
Once your knowledge base is imported, you can
fine tune the important results by editing the
question and answer pairs. As seen here. There
is the chat box. So you can converse with your
bot through a chat box. I wouldn't say it's
particularly a feature of q&a maker, but I just
want you to know that's how you would interact
with it. So when you're using the q&a maker AI,
the Azure bot service the bot composer, or via
channels, you'll get an embeddable one, you'll
see this box where you can start typing in your
questions and and get back the answers to test
it. Here. An example is a multi turn conversation.
So somebody asked a question, a generic question.
And that said, Hey, are you talking about AWS or
Azure, which is kinda like a follow up prompt. And
we'll talk about multiturn here in a second, but
that's something I want you to know about. Okay.
So chit chat is a feature in q&a maker that
allows you to easily add pre populated sets of
top chit chats into your knowledge base. The
data set has about 100 scenarios of chit chat in
voices of multiple personas. So the idea
is like if someone says something random,
like how are you doing? What's the weather today,
things that your bot wouldn't necessarily know.
It has like canned answers, and it's going to be
different based on how you want the response to be
okay. There's a concept of layered ranking. So the
q&a maker system is a layered ranking approach the
data stored in Azure Search, which also serves
as the first ranking layer, the top result for
from Azure Search are then passed through q&a
makers and LP ranking model to produce the final
results and confidence score. Just touching on
multi turn conversation is a follow up prompt
and context to manage the multiple turns known
as multi turn for your bot from one question
to another when a question can't be answered
in a single turn. That is when you're using
multi turn conversation. So q&a maker provides
multi turn prompts and active learning to help
you improve your questions based on key answer
pairs, and it gives you the opportunity to connect
questions and answer pairs. The connection allows
the client app position to provide a top answer
and provide more questions refine the search for
a final answer. After the knowledge base receives
questions from users at the Publish endpoint,
can I make replies active learning to these
rules or questions to suggest changes to your
knowledge base to improve the quality alright.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And we
are looking at Azure bot service. So the Azure
bot services an intelligent serverless bot service
that scales on demand used for creating publishing
and managing bots. So you can register and
publish a variety of bots from the Azure portal.
So here there's a bunch of ones I've never heard
of, probably with third party providers partnered
with Azure. And then there's the ones that we
would know like the Azure health health bot,
the Azure bot, or the webapp bot, which
is more of a generic one. So Azure bot
service bop bop bot service can integrate your bot
with other Azure, Microsoft or third party service
services via channel so you can have a direct
line out Alexa, office 365, Facebook, Keke line,
Microsoft Teams, Skype, Twilio and more. Alright,
and two things that are commonly associated with
the Azure bot service is the Bot Framework and bot
composer. In fact, it was really hard just to make
make this slide here because they just weren't
very descriptive on it. Because I wanted to push
these other two things here. Let's talk about
the Bot Framework SDK. So the Bot Framework SDK,
which is now version four is an Open Source
SDK that enables developers to model and build
sophisticated conversations. The Bot Framework
along with the Azure bot service provides an
end to end workflow. So we can design build,
test, publish, connect, and evaluate. Are
bots. okay with this. With this framework,
developers can create bots that use speech,
understand natural language, handle questions,
answers, and more. The Bot Framework includes
a modular, extensible SDK for building bots, as
well as tools, templates and related AI services.
Then you have Bot Framework composer. And this
is built on top of the Bot Framework SDK. It's
an open source IV for developers to author test
provision and manage conversational experiences.
You can download, it's an app on Windows OS
X, and Linux is probably built using like
web technology. And so here is the actual app
there. And so you can see there's kind of a
bit of a flow and things you can do in there. So
you can either you see or note to build your bot,
you can deploy the bot to the Azure web apps or
Azure Functions. You have templates to build q&a
maker bot enterprise or personal assistant bot
language bot calendar, or people bought. You can
test and debug via the Bot Framework emulator, and
has a built in package manager. There's a lot more
to these things. But again, at the AI 900 this
is all we need to know. But yeah, there you go.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And we
are looking at Azure Machine Learning service,
I want you to know there's a classic
version of the service, it's still
accessible in the portal. This is not
an exam, we are going to 100% avoid it.
It has severe limitations, we cannot transfer
anything over from the closet to the new one.
So the one we're going to focus on is the Azure
Machine Learning service. You do create studios
within it. So you'll hear me say Azure Machine
Learning Studio and I'm referring to the new one,
a service that simplifies running AI ml work
related workloads allowing you to build flexible
automated ml pipelines, use Python or R run
deep learning workloads such as TensorFlow,
we can make Jupyter Notebooks in here. So
build and document your machine learning
models as you build them, share and collaborate
Azure Machine Learning SDK for Python. So an SDK
designed specifically to interact with the Azure
Machine Learning Services. It does ml Ops, machine
learning operations, so end to end automation
of ml model pipelines, CIC D training inference,
Azure Machine Learning designer. So this is a drag
and drop interface to visually build test deploy
machine learning models, technically, pipelines, I
guess, as a data labeling service, assemble a team
of humans to label your training data responsible
in machine learning. So model fairness,
through disparity metrics, and mitigate unfairness
at the time of the service is not very good,
but it's supposed to tie in with the responsible
AI that Microsoft is always promoting. Okay.
So once we launch our own studio with
an Azure Machine Learning service,
you're gonna get this nice big bar, navigation
left hand side, it shows you there's a lot of
stuff that's in here. So let's just break it down
on what all these things are. So for authoring,
we got notebooks these are Jupyter, notebooks
and ID to write Python code to build ml models.
They kind of have their own preview, which I don't
really like. But there's a way to bridge it over
to Jupyter Notebooks or into Visual Studio
code. We have auto ml completely automated
process to build and train ml models. So if you're
limited to only three types of models, but still,
that's great. We have the designers of visual
drag and drop designer to construct end to end
ml pipelines. For assets we have data sets of
data that you can upload which we will be used
which will be used for training Experiments when
you run a training job, they are detailed here,
pipelines, ml workflows, you have built or
have used in the designer model. So a model
registry containing train models that can be
deployed endpoints. So when you deploy a model,
it's hosted on accessible endpoint. So you're
going to be able to access it via a REST API,
or maybe the SDK for managing got compute
the underlying computing instances used
for notebooks, training and inference,
environments, reproducible Python environment for
machine learning experiments, data stores a data
repository where your data resides, data labeling,
so you have a human with ml assisted labeling
to label your data for supervised learning,
Link services, external service, you can connect
to the workspace such as Azure synapse analytics.
Let's take a look at the types of compute that is
available in our Azure Machine Learning Studio,
we got four categories, we have compute
instances, development workstations that
data scientists can use to work with data and
models, compute clusters to scalable clusters of
VMs, for on demand processing, experimentation,
code, deployment targets for predictive services
that use your trained models, and attach compute
links to existing Azure compute resources such as
Azure VMs. And Azure Data brick clusters. Now,
what's interesting here is like with this compute,
you can see that you can open it in Jupiter labs,
Jupiter VS code, our studio and terminal. But
you can you can work with your computers as your
development workstations directly in the studio,
which that's the way I do it. What's interesting
is for inference, that's when you're want to make
a prediction, you use Azure Kubernetes service or
Azure Container instance, I didn't see it show up
under here. So I'm kind of confused whether that's
where it appears. Maybe we'll discover as we do
the follow logs that they do appear here, but
I'm not sure about that one. But yeah, those are
the four there, okay. So within Azure Machine
Learning Studio, we can do some data labeling,
so we create data labeling jobs to prepare your
ground truth. For supervised learning, you have
two options human in the loop labeling, you have
a team of humans that will apply labeling, these
are humans, you grant access to labeling, machine
learning assists to deal with labeling, you will
use ml to perform labeling. So you can export the
label data for machine learning, experimentation,
any time, your users often export multiple times
and train different models. rather than wait for
all the images to be labeled. Images, labels
can be exported in cocoa format. That's why
we talked about cocoa a lot earlier in our data
set section as your machine learning data set.
And this is the data set format that makes it easy
to use for training and Azure machine learning. So
generally, you want to use that format. The idea
is you would choose a labeling Task Type. And that
way you would have this UI and then people go in
and just click buttons and do the labeling. Okay.
So as your ml data store securely connects you
to storage services on Azure without putting your
authentication credentials and the integrity
of your original data source at risk. So here
is the example of data sources that are available
to us in the studio. And let's just go quickly
through them. So we have Azure Blob Storage. This
is data that is stored as objects distributed
across many machines, as your file share a
mountable file share via SMB and NFS protocols
as your data lake storage Gen two, this blob
searches for vast amounts of big data analytics,
as your SQL is a fully managed MS SQL relational
database as your Postgres database, this is an
open source relational database, often considered
an object related database preferred by developers
as your MySQL, another open
source relational database,
the most popular one and considered
a pure relational database, okay.
So as your ml data sets makes it easy to register
your datasets for use with your ml workloads. So
what you do is you'd add a data set and you
get a bunch of metadata associated with it.
And you can also upload a dish like the data set
again to have multiple versions. So you'll have
a current version and a latest version, it's
very easy to get started working with them,
because we'll have some sample code that's for
the Azure ML SDK to import that into, into your
Jupyter notebooks. For datasets, you can generate
profiles that will give you summary statistics,
distribution of data and more, you will have to
use a compute instance to generate that data.
So you'd press the Generate profile, and you'd
have that stored I think it's in blob storage.
There are open data sets is they're publicly
hosted data sets that are commonly used for
learning how to build ml models. So if you go
to open data sets, you just choose one. And so
this is a curated list of open data sets
that you can quickly add to your data store.
Great for learning how to use auto
ml or Azure Machine Learning designer
or any kind of ml workload if you're
new to it. That's why we covered
amnesty and cocoa earlier just because those are
some common data sets there. But there you go.
Take a look here at Azure ML experiments. This is
a logical grouping of Azure runs and runs Act is
the act of running ml tasks on a virtual machine
or container. So here's a list of them. And it can
run various types of ml tasks. So scripts could
be pre processing, auto ml, a training pipeline,
but what it's not gonna include is inference. And
what I mean is once you've deployed your model or
pipeline, and you make predictions via request,
it's just not going to show up under here. Okay?
Okay, so we have Azure ML pipelines, which is
an executable workflow of a complete machine
learning task Not to be confused with Azure
pipelines, which is part of Azure DevOps,
or Data Factory, which has its own pipelines, it's
a total, totally separate thing here. So subtasks
are encapsulated as a series of steps within the
pipeline. Independent steps allow multiple data
scientists to work on the same pipeline at the
same time without overtaxing compute resources.
Separate steps also make it easy to use
different compute type sizes for each step.
When you rerun a pipeline, the run jumps
to the steps that need to be rerun,
such as the updated training script steps do not
need to be rerun, and they will be skipped. After
a pipeline has been published, you can configure
a REST endpoint, which allows you to rerun the
pipeline from any platform or stack. There's two
ways to build pipelines, you can use the Azure
ML designer or pre bakley, using Azure Machine
Learning Python SDK. So here's an example of some
code. Just make a note here, I mean, it's not
that important. But notice as you create steps,
okay, and then you assemble all the
steps into a pipeline here. Alright.
So Azure Machine Learning designer lets you
quickly build as your ml pipelines without
having to write any code. So here is what it looks
like. And over there, you can see our pipeline
is quite visual. And on the left hand side, you
have a bunch of assets you can drag out that are
pre built there. So it's a really fast way for
building a pipeline. So you do have to have a good
understanding of ml pipelines end to end to make
good use of it. Once you've trained your pipeline,
you can create an inference pipeline, so you drop
down and you'd say whether you want it to be real
or batch, or you can toggle between them later.
So I mean, there's a lot to this service. But
for the 100, we don't have
to go diving too deep, okay.
So as your ml models are the model registry
allows you to create, manage and track your
registered models as incremental versions under
the same name. So each time you register a model
with the same name as an existing one, the
registry assures that it's a new version.
Additionally, you can provide metadata tags
and use tags when you search for models.
So yeah, it's just really easy way to share
and deploy or download your models, okay?
As your MLM points allow you to deploy
machine learning models as a web service.
So the workflow for deploying models,
register the model, prepare an entry script,
prepare an inference configuration, deploy the
model locally to ensure everything works, compute,
choose a compute, Target, redeploy the model to
the cloud test the resulting web service. So we
have two options here real time endpoints endpoint
that provides remote access to invoke the ML model
service running on either Azure Kubernetes
service Eks, or Azure Container instances ACI,
then we have pipeline endpoint. So endpoint that
provides remote access to invoke an ml pipeline,
you can parameterize the pipeline endpoint
for manage repeatability in batch scoring
and retraining scenarios. And so you can deploy
a model to an endpoint yet, it will either be
deployed to a Eks or ACI, as we said earlier, and
the thing is, is that when you do do that, just
understand that that's going to be shown under
the A Ks or ACI within the Azure portal. It's
not consolidated under the Azure Machine Learning
Studio. When you've deployed a real time endpoint,
you can test the endpoint by sending either a
single request or batch request. So they have
a nice form here with single or it's like here,
it's a CSV that you can send. So there you go.
So Azure has a built in Jupiter like notebook
editor, so you can build and train your ml models.
And so here is an example of it. I personally
don't like it too much. But that's okay,
because we have some other options. To make it
easier. All you do is you choose your compute
instance, to run the notebook, you'll choose your
kernel, which is a pre loaded programming language
and programming libraries for different use
cases. But that's a Jupiter kernel concept there.
So you can open the notebook at a
more familiar ID such as VS code,
Jupyter, notebook classic or Jupiter lab. So you
go there, drop it down, choose it and open it
up. And now you're in a more familiar territory.
The VS code one is exactly the same experience as
the one in Azure or Azure ML studio. I
personally don't like it. I think most
people are going to be using the notebooks but
it's great that they have all those options.
So Azure automated machine learning, also
known as auto ml automates the process of
creating an ml model. So with Azure auto, ml
you supply a data set, choose a test type,
then auto ml will train and tune your model. So
here are test types, let's quickly go through
them. So we have classification, when you need
to make a prediction based on several classes, so
binary classification, multi class classification
regression, when you need to predict a continuous
number value, and then time series forecasting
when you need to predict the value based on time.
So just look at them a little bit more in detail.
So classification is a type of supervised learning
in which the model learns using training data and
apply those learnings to new data. So here is an
example. Or this is just the option here. And so
the goal of classification is to predict which
categories new data will fall into based on
learning from its training data. So binary
classification is a record is labeled out of two
possible labels. So maybe it's true or false, zero
or one, just two values. multiclass classification
is a record is labeled out of range of out of a
range of labels. And so can be like happy, sad,
mad or rad. And just, you know, I can see there's
a spelling mistake there. But yeah, there should
be an F. So let's just correct that. There we go.
You can also apply deep learning and so if you
turned deep learning on you probably want to use
a GPU compute instance, just because or compute
cluster because deep learning really prefers
GPUs. Okay. Looking at regression, it's also a
type of supervised learning where the model learns
using training data and applies those learnings
to new data, but it's a bit different, where the
goal of aggression is to predict a variable in the
future, then you have time series forecasting and
this sounds a lot like regression because it is,
so forecast revenue inventory sales or customer
demand, an automated time series experiment that
is treated as a multivariate regression problem,
past time series values are pivoted to become
additional dimensions for the regressor together
with other predictors, unlike classical time
series methods has an advantage of naturally
incorporating multiple contextual variables and
their relationship to one another during training.
So use cases here or dance configurations, I
should say, holiday detection and future position
time series, deep learning neural networks.
So you got auto ri ma profit forecast TCN.
Many models supports through
grouping, rolling origin,
cross validation, configurable labs rolling
window aggregate features, so there you go.
So within auto ml, we have data
guardrails, and these are run by
auto ml when automatic feature rotation is
enabled, it's a sequence of checks to ensure
high quality input data is being used to
train the model. So just to show you some
information here. So the idea is that could
apply validation split handling so the input
data has been split for validation to improve
the performance, then you have missing feature
value imputation so no features missing
values were detected in training data,
high cardinality feature detection, your inputs
were analyzed, and no high cardinality features
were detected. High cardinality means
like if you have too many dimensions,
it becomes very dense or hard to process the
data. So that's something good to check against.
Let's talk about auto ml is automatic feature
isolation. So during model training with auto ml,
one of the following scaling or normalization
techniques will be applied to each model. The
first is standard scale rapper standardized
features by removing the mean and scaling to
unit variants. min max scalar transform features
by scaling each feature by the columns minimum
maximum max ABS scalar scale each feature by its
maximum absolute value, robust scale our scales
features by the quantitative quantal range, a
PCA linear dimensionality reduction using single
value decomposition of the data to project it
to lower dimensional space. dimension reduction
is very useful if your data is too complex. And
let's say you have data you have too many labels
like 20 3040 labels for like four categories to
pick out of you want to reduce the dimensions
so that your machine learning model is not
overwhelmed. So then you have truncated SVD
wrappers. So the transformer performs linear
dimensionality reduction by means of truncated
single singular value decomposition contrary to
PCA, the estimator does not send her the data
before computing the singular value
decomposition, which means it can work with
spicy sparse matrices, efficiently sparse
normalization to each sample that is each
row of the data matrix which with at least
one zero component is rescaled independently
of other samples, that is norm. So one
l or two l two, I can refer to it or L.
Anyway, I one and, and I two. Okay? So the thing
is, is that on the exam, they're probably not
going to be asking these questions but I just
like to get you exposure, but I just want to
show you that auto ml is doing all this. This
is like pre processing stuff, you know, like
this is stuff that you'd have to do, and so it's
just taking care of the stuff for Are you okay?
So within Azure auto ml, they have a feature
called model selection. And this is the task
of selecting a statistical model from a set of
candidate models. And Azure auto ml will use
different, or many different ml algorithms that
will recommend the best performing candidates. So
here's a list. And I want to just point out, down
below, there's three pages, there's 53 models,
that's a lot of models. And so you can see that
the one I chose is its top candidate was called
voting ensemble, that's an ensemble algorithm,
that's where you take two weak ml models,
combine them together to make a more stronger
one. And notice here, it will show us the results.
And this is what we're looking for, which is the
primary metric, the highest value should indicate
that that's the model we should want to use, you
can get an explanation of the model called that's
known as explainability. And now if
you're a data scientist, you might
be a bit smarter and say, Well, I know this one
should be better. So I'll use this and tweak it.
But you know, if you don't know you're
doing just go with the top line, okay.
So we just saw that we had a top candidate model,
and there could be an explanation to understand
as to the effectiveness of this, this is called
MX L. So machine learning explainability This
is the process of explaining interpreting
ml or deep learning models, MX, m, l x, can help
machine learning developers to better understand
interpret models behavior. So after your top
candidate models selected by Azure auto ml,
you can get an explanation of internals
of various factors. So model performance
data set, explore aggregate feature importance,
individual feature importance. So I mean, yeah,
this is aggregate. So what it's looking at, and
it's actually cut off here, but it's saying that
these are the most important ones that affect
how the the models outcome. So I think this is
the diabetes data data set. So BMI would be one,
that would be a huge influence there, there, okay.
So the primary metric is a parameter that
determines the metric to be used during
the mall training for optimization. So we for
classification, we have a few and regression
and time series, we have a few. But you'll have
these task types. And underneath, you'll choose
the additional configuration. And that's where
you can override the primary metric, it might
just auto detect it for you. So you don't have to
because it might sample some of your data set to
just kind of guess. But you might have to override
it yourself. Just going through some scenarios.
And we'll break it down into two categories. So
here we have suited for larger datasets that are
well balanced. well balanced means that your data
set like is evenly distributed. So if you have
classifications for A and B, let's say you have
100, and 100, they're well balanced, right,
you don't have one data set much a subset
of your data set much larger than the other
that's labeled. So for accuracy, this is
great for image classification, sentiment
analysis term prediction, for average precision
score weighted is for sentiment analysis, nor
macro recall term prediction for precision score
weighted, uncertain as to what that would be good
for maybe sentiment analysis suited for smaller
data sets that are imbalanced. So that's where
your data set like you might have like 10 records
for one and 500 for the other on the label.
So you have AUC weighted fraud detection, image
classification, anomaly detection, spam detection,
on to regression scenarios, we'll break it down
into ranges. So when you have a very wide range,
Spearman correlation works really well are
to score. This is great for airline delay
salary estimation, but resolution time,
when you're looking at smaller ranges,
we're talking about normalized root square
mean to error. So price predictions,
review tips, score predictions,
for normalized mean absolute error,
it's going to be just another one here, they
don't give a description for time series,
it's the same thing. It's just in the context
of time series of forecasting. Alright.
Another option we can change is the validation
type when we're setting up our ML model. So
validation, model validation is when we compare
the results of our training data set to our test
data set model validation occurs after we train
the model. And so you can just drop it down
there, and we have some options. So auto k fold
cross validation, Monte Carlo cross validation,
train validation split, I'm not going to really
get into the details of that. I don't think it'll
show up on the AI 900 exam. But I just want you to
be aware of that you do have those options, okay.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And
we're taking a look here at custom vision.
And this is a fully managed no code service
to quickly build your own classification,
and object detection ml models. The service is
hosted on its own isolate domain at www custom
vision.ai. So the first idea is you upload your
images of bring your own labelled images or custom
vision to quickly add tags to any unlabeled data
images. You use the labeled images to teach custom
vision, the concepts you care about, which is
training, and you use a simple REST API that calls
to quickly tag images. With your new custom
computer vision model so you can evaluate, okay.
So when we launch custom vision, we have to
create a project. And with that, we need to choose
a project type. And we have classification and
object detection. Reviewing classification, here,
you have the option between multi labels. So
when you want to apply many tags to an image,
so think of an image that contains both a cat and
a dog, you have multi class, so when you only have
one possible tag to apply to an image, so it's
either an apple, banana, and orange, it's not
multiples of these things.
You have object detection,
this is when we want to detect various objects
in an image. And you also need to choose a
domain a domain is a Microsoft managed data
set that is used for training the ML model.
There are different domains that are suited
for different use cases. So let's go take a
look first at image classification domains. So
here is the big list of domains being over here.
Okay, and we'll go through these here. So
general is optimized for a broad range of
image classification tasks. If none of the none
of the other specified domains are appropriate,
or you're unsure of which domain to choose Select
one of the general domains so G, or a one is
optimized for better accuracy with comparable
inference time as general domain recommended for
larger datasets or more difficult user scenarios.
This domain requires more training time,
then you have a to optimize for better accuracy
with faster adverts times than a one and general
domains recommended for more most datasets this
domain requires less training time, then general
and a one, you have food optimized for photographs
or dishes as you would see them on a restaurant
menu. If you want to classify photographs of
individual fruits or vegetables use food domains.
So that we have optimized for recognizable
landmarks both natural and artificial. This domain
works best when landmark is clearly visible in
the photograph, this domain works even if the lend
mark is slightly obstructed by people in front of
it. Then you have retail so optimized for images
that are found in a shopping cart or shopping
website. If you want a high precision classifying
classified in between dresses, pants shirts
uses domain contact domains optimized for the
constraints of real time classification on the
edge. Okay, then we have object detection domain,
so this one's a lot shorter, so I'll get
through a lot quicker. So optimize for
a broad range of object detection tasks if
none of the other domains are appropriate,
or you're unsure of which domain choose the
general one a one optimize for better accuracy and
comparable inference time than the general domain
recommended for most accurate region. locations,
larger data sets or more difficult use case
scenarios, the domain requires more training
results are not deterministic expect plus minus
1% mean average precision difference with the same
training data provided you have logo optimized for
finding brands, logos and images products on shelf
so optimized for detecting and classifying
products on the shelf. So there you go.
Okay, so let's get some more practical knowledge
of the service. So for image classification,
you're gonna upload multiple images and apply
single or multiple labels to the entire image. So
here I have a bunch of images uploaded. And then
I have my tags over here. And they could either be
multi or singular. For object detection, you apply
tags to objects in an image for data labeling,
and you hover your cursor over the image custom
vision uses ml to show bounding bounding boxes
of possible objects that are not yet been labeled.
If it does not detect it, you can also just click
and drag to draw out whatever square you want.
So here's one where I tagged it up quite a bit,
you have to have at least 50 images on every
tag to train. So just be aware of that when you
are tagging your images. When you're training,
your model is ready when you and you have two
options. So you have quick training that's trained
quickly, but it will be less accurate, you have
advanced training, this increases compute time to
improve your results. So for advanced training,
basically, you just have this thing that you move
to the right. With each iteration of training,
our ML model will improve the evaluation metrics.
So precision recall, it's going to vary. We're
going to talk about the metrics here in a moment,
but the probability threshold value determines
when to stop training, when our evaluation metric
meets our desired thresholds. So these are just
additional options where when you're training,
you can move this left to right, and these left
to right, okay. And then when we get a results
back, we're gonna get some metrics here. So
we have evaluation master. So we have precision
being exact, inaccurate, selects items that are
relevant, recalls that sensitivity or known
as true positive rate, how many relevant items
returned average precision, it's important
that you remember these because they might
ask you that on the exam. So for cut when we're
looking at object detection, and we're looking
at the evaluation metric outcomes for this one, we
have precision recall and mean average precision.
Once we have deployed our pipeline, it makes sense
that we go ahead and give it a quick test to make
sure it's working correctly to press Click Click
test button and you can upload your image and it
will tell you so this one says it's worth, when
you're ready to publish, you just hit the publish
button. And then you'll get some prediction
URL and information so you can invoke it.
One other feature that's kind of useful
is the smart labelers. So once you've
loaded some training data within a canal,
make suggestions, right. So you can't do this
right away. But once it has some data, it's like,
it's like kind of a prediction that is not 100%,
guaranteed, right, and it just helps you build
up your training data set a lot faster. Very
useful. If you have a very large data set,
this is known as ml assisted labeling, okay.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro. And in
this follow along, we're gonna set up a studio
with an Azure Machine Learning service, so that
it will be the basis for all the fall logs here.
So what I want you to do is go all the way the
top here, and type in Azure machine learning.
And you're looking for this one that looks like
a science bottle here. And we'll go ahead and
create ourselves our Machine Learning Studio. And
so I'll create a new one here, and I'll just say,
my studio. I will hit OK. And we'll name the
workspace. So I will say my work workplace
will maybe say and I'll
workplace here. For containers,
there are nodes that we will create all that
stuff for us. I'll hit create and create.
And so what we're going to do here
is just wait for that creation, okay?
Alright, so after a short little wait there, it
looks like our studio set up. So we'll go to that
resource launch the studio and where are now in.
So there's a lot of stuff in here. But generally,
the first thing you'll ever want to do is get
yourself a notebook going. So in the top left
corner, I'm going to go to notebooks. And what
we'll need to do is load some files in here. Now
they do have some Sample Files, like how to use
Azure ML. So if we just quickly go through here,
you know, maybe we'll want to look at something
like Ms NIST here. And we'll go ahead and open
this one. And we'll just go ahead and clone
this. And we'll just clone it over here.
Okay, and the idea is that we want to get
this notebook running. And so notebooks have
to be backed by some kind of compute. So up
here, it says, No compute found, and etc. So
what we can do here, I'm just gonna go back to my
files, oh, it went back there for me. But what I'm
going to do is go all the way down. Actually, I'll
just expand this up here makes it a bit easier,
close this tab out. But what we'll do is go
down to compute. And here we have our four
types of compute to compute instances
is when we're running notebooks,
compute clusters, is when we're doing
training inference clusters is when we have
a inference pipeline. And then attached computers
bringing things like hdn sites or data bricks into
here, but for compute instances is what we need,
we'll get ahead and go new, you'll notice they
have the option between CPU and GPU. GPU is much
more expensive. So it's like 90 cents per hour.
For a notebook, we do not need anything super
powerful. Notice, it'll say here, development
on notebooks, IDs, lightweight testing, here, it's
as classical ml model training, auto ml pipelines,
etc. So I want to make this a bit cheaper
for us here. Because we're going to be using
the notebook to run cognitive services and those
costs next to nothing like they don't take much
compute power. And for some other ones, we
might do something a bit larger. For this,
this is good enough. So I'll go ahead and
hit next. I'm just gonna say my notebook
instance here. We'll go ahead and hit Create.
And so we're just gonna have to wait for that
to finish creating and running and when
it is, I'll see you back here in a moment.
Alright, so after a short little wait there, it
looks like our server is running. And you can even
see here it shows you you can launch in Jupiter
labs, Jupiter VS code, our studio or the terminal.
But what I'm going to do is go back all the way
to our notebooks just so we have some consistency
here, I want you to notice that it's now running
on this compute. If it's not, you can go ahead and
select it. And it also loaded in Python 3.6, there
is 3.8. Right now, it's not a big deal which one
you use. But that is the kernel, like how it will
run this stuff. Now, this is all interesting. But
I don't want to run this right now what I want to
do is get those cognitive services into here. So
what we can do is just go up here and we'll choose
editors and edit in Jupiter lab. What that should
do is open up a new tab here is it opening. If
it's not opening, what we can do is go to compute.
Sometimes it's a bit more responsive. If we just
click there, it's the same way of getting to it.
I don't know why, but just sometimes that link
doesn't work when you're in the notebook. And what
we can do is while we're in here now we can see
that this is where this is An example project is
okay. But what we want to do is get
those cognitive services in here. So
I don't know if I showed it to you yet, but
I have a repository, I just gotta go find
it. It's somewhere on my screen. Here it is.
Okay, so I have a repo called the free az, AZ
night free, AZ I should be ai 900, I think I'll
go ahead and change that, or that is going to get
confusing. Okay, so what I want you to
do here is, we'll get this loaded in. So
this is a public directory, I'm just thinking,
there's a couple ways we can do it, we can go
and I use the terminal to grab it, what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to go download the zip.
And this is just one of the easiest ways to
install it, and we need to place it somewhere.
So here are my downloads. And I'm just going
to drag it out here. Okay. And what we'll do
is upload that there. So I can't remember if it
lets you upload entire folders, we'll give it a
go see if it lets us maybe rename this to the
free AZ or ai 900 there, we'll say open. Yeah,
so it's individual file. So it's not that big of a
deal, but we can go ahead and select it like that.
And maybe we'll just take him to the folder
and here we'll say this cognitive services.
Okay. And what we'll do here is keep on
uploading some stuff. So we have assets.
So I have a couple loose files there. And
I know we have crew groups will have crew.
Oops. Sometimes it's not as responsive. We want
OCR, I believe we have on called movie reviews.
So we'll go into OCR here and upload the files
that we have. So we have a few files there.
And we'll go back a directory here. And I
know movie reviews are just static files.
And we have an objects folder. So
we will go back here to objects.
And then we'll go back and to crew
and we need a folder called Wharf
a folder called Crusher, a folder called data.
And so for each of these, we have some images.
Think Ron Wharf, right? Yeah, we are okay,
great. So we will quickly upload all these
I will technically we don't really
need to upload any of these walls,
these images we don't but I'm going to
put them here anyway, I just remembered
that these we just upload directly to the
service. But because I'm already doing it,
I'm just gonna put them here, even though
we're not going to do anything with them.
All right. And so now we are all set up to do
some cognitive services. So I'll see you the
next video. Alright, so now that we have our work
environment set up, what we can do is go ahead
and get Cognitive Services hooked up, because we
need that service in order to interact with it.
Because if we open up any of these, you're gonna
notice we have a cognitive key endpoint that we're
going to need. So what I want you to do is go
back to your Azure Portal. And at the top here,
we'll type in cognitive services. Now the thing
is, is that all these services are individualized,
but at some point, they did group them together,
and you're able to use them through a unified key
and API endpoint. That's what this is. And that's
the way we're going to do it. So let's say add,
and it brought us to the marketplace.
So I'm just going to type in cognitive
services. And then just click this
one here. And we'll hit Create.
And we'll make a new one here. I'm gonna call
my cogs services, say, Okay, I prefer to be
in US East, I believe in us West, it's fine.
And so in here, we'll just say my cog services.
And if it doesn't like that, I'll
just put some numbers in. There we go.
We'll do standard so we will be charged something
for that. Let's go take a look at the pricing.
So you can see that the pricing is quite
variable here, but it's like you'd have to
do 1000 transactions. Before you are billed,
so I think we're going to be okay for billing.
We'll check boxes here, we'll go down below,
it's telling us about responsible AI. Notice,
sometimes services will actually have you checkbox
it. But in this case, it just tells us there.
And we'll go ahead and hit Create.
And I don't believe this took very long, so
we'll give it a second here. Yep, it's all
deployed. So we'll go to this resource here. And
what we're looking for are keys and endpoints.
And so we have two keys and two endpoints, we
only need a single key. So I'm going to copy this
endpoint over, we're gonna go over to Jupiter
lab, and I'm just going to paste this in here.
I'm just gonna put it in all the ones
that need it. So this one needs one.
This one needs one. This one needs one. And this
one needs one. And we will show the key here,
I guess doesn't show but it copies. Of course,
I will end up deleting my key before you ever
see it. But this is something you don't want to
share publicly. And usually, you don't want to
embed keys directly into a notebook. But this is
the only way to do it. So this is how it is with
Azure. So yeah, all our keys are installed. Going
back to the cognitive services, nothing super
exciting here. But it does tell us what services
work with it. You'll see there's an asterisk
beside custom vision, because we're gonna access
that through another app. But yeah, cognitive
services all set up. And so that means we are
ready to start doing some of these labs. Okay.
All right. So let's take a look here
at computer vision first. And computer
vision is actually used for a variety
of different services. As you will see,
it's kind of an umbrella for a lot of different
things. But the one in particular that we're
looking at here is describe image in stream.
If we go over here to the documentation,
this operation generates description of
image in a human readable language. And with
complete sentences, the description is
based on a collection of content tags,
which also returned by the operation. Okay, so
let's go see what that looks like in action.
So the first thing is, is that we need to install
this Azure Cognitive Services vision computer
vision. Now we do have a kernel and these aren't
installed by default, they're not part of the
machine learning the Azure Machine Learning SDK
for Python, I believe that's pre installed. But
these AI services are not. So what we'll do
is go ahead and run it this way. And you'll
notice where it says pip install, that's how
it knows to install. And once that is done,
we'll go run our requirements here. So we have
the OS, which is for usually handling up like OS
layer stuff, we have met matplotlib, which is to
visually plot things, and we're gonna use that to
show images and draw borders, we need to handle
images. I'm not sure if we're using NumPy here,
but I have NumPy loaded. And then here we have the
Azure Cognitive Services vision, computer vision,
we're going to load the client. And then we have
the credentials. And these are generic credentials
for the cognitive services credentials. It's
commonly used for most of the services and
some exceptions, they the API's do not support
them yet, but I imagine they will in the future.
So just notice that when we run something, it will
show a number. If there's an asterisk, it means it
hasn't ran yet. So I'll go ahead and hit play up
here. So it was an Astra can we get her to, and
we'll go ahead and hit play again. And now those
are loaded in and so we'll go ahead and hit play.
Okay, so here we have just packaged our
credentials together. So we passed our key
into here, and then will now load in the client,
install, pass our endpoint and our key. Okay,
so hit play. So now we we just want to load
our image. So here we're loading assets
data dot jpg, just make sure that that is
there. So we have assets, and there it is.
And we're going to load it as a stream
because you have to pass streams along.
So hit play. You'll see that it now ran. And
so now we'll go ahead and make that call.
Okay, great. And so we're getting some data back.
And notice we have some properties person while
indoor man pointing captions. It's
not showing all the information,
sometimes you have to extract it out. But we'll
take a look here. So this is a way of showing
matplotlib in line. I don't think we have to
run it here, but I have it in here anyway.
And so what it's going to do is it's going to
show us the image, right? So it's going to print
us the image, and it's going to grab whatever
caption is returns to see how there's captions.
So we're going to iterate through the captions.
That's going to give us a confidence score saying
it thinks it's this so let's
see what it comes up with.
Okay, and so here it says brand spider spider
looking at a camera. So that is the actor who
plays data on Star Trek as a confidence score.
57 point 45% even though it's 100% correct,
they probably don't know contextual things
like in the sense of like pop culture,
like they don't know probably search for
characters, but they're gonna be able to identify
celebrities because it's in their database.
So that is the first introduction to computer,
computer vision there. But the key things you want
to remember here is that we use this describe an
image stream. And that we get this confidence
score and we get this contextual information.
Okay. And so that's the first I'll
move on to maybe custom vision next.
Alright, so let's take a look at custom vision.
So we can do some classification and object
detection. So the thing is, is that it's possible,
it's possible to launch custom vision through the
Marketplace. So if we go, we're not going to
do it this way. If you type in custom vision,
it never shows up here. But if you go to the
marketplace here, and type in custom vision,
and you go here, you can create it this way. But
the way I like to do it, I think it's a lot easier
to do is we'll go up the top here and type in
custom vision.ai. And you'll come to this website.
And what you'll do is go ahead and sign in,
it's going to connect to your Azure account.
And once you're in, you can go ahead here and
create a new project. So the first one here
is I'm just gonna call this the Star Trek crew.
We're gonna use this to identify different Star
Trek members, we'll go down here, and we haven't
yet created a resource. So we'll go create new,
my custom vision resource. We'll drop this
down, we'll put this in our cog services,
we'll go stick with us West as much as we
can. Here, we have fo and so fo is blocked
out for me to just choose. So I think
fo is the free tier, but I don't get it.
And once we're back here, we'll go down below and
choose our standard. And we're going to have a lot
of options here. So we have between classification
and object detection. So classification,
is when you have an image and you just want to
say, what, what is this image, right. And so we
have two modes where we can say, let's apply
multiple labels. So let's say there were two
people in the photo or whether there was a dog and
cat. And I think this example is a dog and a cat.
Or you just have a single class where it's like,
what is the one thing that is in this photo, it
can only be of one of the particular categories.
This is the one we're going to do multiclass,
we have a bunch of different domains here.
And if you want to, you can go ahead and read
about all the different domains and their best
use case, but we're going to stick with a two
that is optimized for it. So that's faster,
right. And that's really good for our demo.
So we're going to choose general a two, I'm
going to go ahead and create this project.
And so now what we need to do is start labeling
our arc our content. So what we'll do is I just
want to go ahead and create the tags ahead
of time. So we'll say Wharf will have data.
And we'll have Crusher. And now what we'll do
is we'll go ahead and upload as images. So,
you know, we upload in the Jupyter Notebook, but
it was totally not necessary. So here is data,
because we're going to do it all through here. And
we'll just apply the data tag to them all at once,
which saves us a lot of time, I love that will
upload now Worf. And I don't want to upload them
all I have this one quick test image we're going
to use to make sure that this works correctly.
And I'm going to choose Worf. And
then we'll go ahead and add Beverly.
There she is. Beverly Crusher. Okay, so we
have all of our images. And I don't know how
this one got in here, but it's under Worf, it
works out totally fine. So what I want to do
is go ahead and train this model, because they're
all labeled. So we have a ground truth. And we'll
let it go ahead and train. So we'll go and press
train. And we have two options, quick training,
advanced training, advanced training, where
we can increase the time for better accuracy.
But honestly, we just want to do quick training.
So I'll go ahead and do quick training. And it's
going to start it's iterative process. Notice on
the left hand side, we have probability threshold,
the minimum probability score for a prediction to
be valid when calculating calculating precision,
and recall. So we, the thing is, is that if
it doesn't at least meet that requirements,
it will quit out. And if it gets above that, that
it might quit out early, just because it's good
enough. Okay. So training doesn't take too long,
it might take five to 10 minutes, I can't remember
how long it takes. But what I'll do is I'll see
you back here in a moment, okay. All right. So
after waiting a short little while here, it looks
like our results are done, we get 100% matches. So
these are our evaluation metrics to say whether
the model was achieved its actual goal or not.
So we have precision recall. And I believe this
is average precision. And so it says that it did
a really good job. So that means that it should
have no problem matching up an image. So in the
top right corner, we have this button that is
called Quick tests. And this is going to give
us the opportunity to quickly test these. So
what we'll do is browse our files locally here.
And actually I'm going to go to Yeah, we'll
go here and we have war. And so I have this
quick image here, we'll test that we'll
see if it actually matches up to be worth.
And it says 98.7%. Worse, that's pretty
good. I also have some additional images
here I just put into the repo to test
against, and we'll see what it matches
up. Because I thought it'd be interesting to
do something that is not necessarily them,
but it's something pretty close to, you know,
it's pretty close to what those are. Okay.
So we'll go to crew here, and First we'll try you.
Okay, and who is the Borg, so he's kind of like an
Android. And so we can see he mostly matches to
data. So that's pretty good. We'll give another
one go. martock is a click on so he should be
matched up to Worf. Very strong match to work.
That's pretty good. And then polaski. She is a
doctor and female, so she should get matched up to
Beverly Crusher. And she does. So this works out
pretty darn well. And I hadn't even tried that. So
it's pretty exciting. So now let's say we want to
go ahead and well, if we want to make predictions,
we could do them in bulk here. I believe
that you could do them in bulk. But anyway.
Yeah, I guess I always thought this was like, I
could have swore, yeah, if we didn't have these
images before, I think that it actually has an
upload option, it's probably just a quick test.
So I'm a bit confused there. But
anyway, so now that this is ready,
what we can do is go ahead and publish it so that
it is publicly accessible. So we'll just say here,
crew model. Okay, and we'll drop that
down, say publish. And once it's published,
now we have this public URL. So this is an
endpoint that we can go hit programmatically.
I'm not going to do that. I mean, we could use
postman to do that. But my point is, is that we've
basically figured it out for classification.
So now that we've done classification,
let's go back here to the division here. And let's
now let's go ahead and do object detection. Okay.
Alright, so we're still in custom vision, let's
go ahead and try out object detection. So object
detection is when you can identify particular
items in a scene. And so this one is going to
be combat just we're going to call it because
we're going to try to detect combat, we have
more domains, here, we're gonna stick with a
general a one. And we'll go ahead and create this
project here. And so what we need to do is add a
bunch of images, I'm going to go ahead and create
our tag, which is going to be called combat, you
can look for multiple different kinds of labels,
but then you need a lot of images. So we're
just gonna keep it simple and have that there,
I'm going to go ahead and add some
images. And we're going to go back
a couple steps here, into our objects. And here
I have a bunch of photos, and we need exactly
15 to train. So we got 1-234-567-8910 1112 1314
1516. And so I threw an additional image in here,
this is the batch test. So we'll leave that out.
And we'll see if that picks up really well. And,
yeah, we got them all here. And so we'll go ahead
and upload those. And we'll hit upload files.
Okay. And we'll say done, and we can
now begin to labels. We'll click into
here and what I want to do if you hover
over it should start detecting things.
If it doesn't, you can click and drag bolt,
click this one. They're all con badges,
so we're not going to tag anything else
here. Okay. So go here, hover over is it
gonna give me the combat? No, so I'm just
right clicking and dragging to get it.
Okay. Okay, do we get this combat? Yes.
Do we get this one? Yep. Simple as that.
Okay, it doesn't always get
it, but most cases it does.
Okay, didn't get that one.
So we'll just drag it out.
Okay, it's not getting that one.
It's interesting. Like, that one's pretty clear.
But it's interesting what it picks out and what
does what does not grab it. So it's not getting
this one, probably because the photo doesn't have
enough contrast. And this one has a lot hoping
that that gives us more data to work with here.
Yeah, I think the higher the
contrast easier for it to
detect those. It's not getting that one.
Not getting that one. Okay, there we go.
Yes, there are a lot I know as
some of these ones that are packed,
but there's only like three
photos that are like this.
They have badges but they're slightly
different. So we're gonna leave those out.
I think it actually had that one,
but we'll just tag it anyway.
And hopefully this will be worth the effort here.
There we go.
I think that was the last one. Okay, great. So
we have all of our tag photos. And what we can
do is go ahead and train the model, same
option, quick training, advanced training,
we're gonna do a quick training here. And notice
that the options are slightly different, we have
probably threshold. And then we have overlap
thresholds. So the minimum percentage of overlap
between predicted bounding boxes and ground truth
boxes to be considered for correct prediction.
So I'll see you back here when it is done.
Alright, so after waiting a little bit a while
here, it looks like it's done. It's trained. And
so precision is at 75%. So precision, the number
will tell you if a tag is predicted by your model,
how likely that it's likely to be. So how likely
did a guess right? Then you have recall? So the
number will tell you out of the tags, which should
be predicted correctly, what percentage does your
model correctly find? So we have 100%. And then
you have mean average precision, this number will
tell you the overall object detector performance
across all the tags. Okay, so what we'll do is
we'll go ahead and do a quick test on this model.
And we'll see how it does. I can't remember if I
actually even ran this. So it'll be curious to see
the first one here. It's not as clearly
visible, it's part of their uniform. So
I'm not expecting you to pick it up. But we'll
see what it does. It picks up pretty much all of
them. exception, this one is definitely not a con
badge. But that's okay. Alicia suggests obviously,
the probability is above the selected threshold.
So if we increase it, we'll just bring it down a
bit. So there it kind of improves it. If
we move it around back and forth. Okay.
So I imagined it via the API, we could choose
that let's go look at our other sample image here.
I'm not seeing it. Where did I save it? Let me
just double check, make sure that it's in the
correct directory here. Okay. Yeah, I saved it
to the wrong place just a moment. I will place it
just call that bench test to one second.
Okay, and so I'll just browse here again.
And so here we have another one. See if
it picks up the badge right here. There
we go. So looks like it works. So yeah,
I guess custom vision is pretty easy to use,
and pretty darn good. So what we'll do is close
this off and make our way back to our Jupiter
labs to move on to our our next lab here, okay.
All right, so let's move on to the face service.
So just go ahead and double click there on the
left hand side. And what we'll do is work our way
from the top. So the first thing we need to do
is make sure that we have the computer vision
installed. So the face service is part of the
Computer Vision API. And once that is done, we'll
go ahead and do our imports. Very similar to last
one. But here we're using the face client, we're
still using the cognitive service credentials
will populate our keys, will you make the face
client and authenticate. And we're going to use
the same image we used prior with our computer
vision, so the data one there, and we'll go ahead
and print out the results. And so we get an object
back. So it's not very clear what it is. But
here if we hit show, okay, here, it's data, and
it's identifying the face IDs are going through
this code. So we're just saying open the image,
we're going to set up our figure for plotting,
it's going to say, Well, how many faces did
it detect in the photo, and so here it says,
detected one face, it will iterate through it.
And then we'll create a bounding box around the
images, we can do that because it returns back the
face rectangles, we get a top left, right, etc.
And we will draw that wrangle on top. So
we have magenta, I could change it to like
three if I wanted to. I don't know what the other
colors are. So I'm not even going to try but yeah,
there it is. And then we annotate with the face
ID that's the unique identifier for the face.
And then we show the image. Okay, so that's
one. And then if we wanted to get more
detailed information, like attributes such as age,
emotion, makeup or gender, this resolution image
wasn't large enough. So I had to find a different
image and do that. So that's one thing you need
to know is if it's not large enough, we won't
process it. So we're just loading data large.
Very similar process, but it is the same thing
detect with stream but now we're passing in
return face attributes. And so here
we're saying the attributes we want.
And there's that list and we went through
it in the lecture content and so here
We'll go ahead and run this. And so
we're getting more information. So
that magenta line is a bit hard to see.
I'm just gonna increase that to three.
Okay, still really hard to see. But
that's okay. So approximately age 44,
I think the actor was a bit younger than
that. Data technically is male presenting,
but he's an Android. So it doesn't necessarily
have a gender, I suppose. He actually is wearing
a lot of makeup. But all it detects is it I guess
it's only Pickler on the lips and the eyes. So it
says he doesn't have makeup. So maybe there's
a color, you know, like eyeshadow or stuff. And
we would detect that in terms of personality.
I like how he's a 002 points, percent. Sad,
but he's neutral, right. So just going
through the code here very quickly. So again,
it's the number of faces so it detected one face.
And then we draw a bounding box around the face
for the detected attributes, it's returned back
in the data here. So we just say, get the phase
attributes, turn it into a dictionary.
And then we can just get those values and
iterate over it. So that's as
complicated as it is. And so there we go.
Alright, so we're on to our next cognitive
service. Let's take a look at form recognizer.
Alright, and so form recognizer, it tries
to identify, like forms and turns them into
readable things. And so they have one for receipts
in particular. So at the top, finally, we're not
using computer computer vision, we actually
have a different one. So this one's Azure AI
form recognizer. So run that there. But this one
in particular isn't up to date in terms of using
it like, notice, all the other ones are using
the cognitive service credential. So for this,
we actually had to use the Azure Key credential,
which was annoying, I tried to use the other one
to be consistent, but I couldn't use it. Okay,
so what we'll do is run our keys like before,
we have a client very similar process. And
this time, we actually have a receipt. And so
we have begin recognize receipt. So it's going
to analyze the receipt information. And then it's
what it's going to do is show us the image. Okay,
just so we have a reference to look at the images
and actually yellow, it's a white background.
I don't know why when it renders out here,
it does that, but that's just what happens. And it
even obscures the server name. I don't know why.
But anyway, if we go down below, this is returned
results up here, right, so we got our results.
And so if we just print out the results, here,
we can see we get a recognized forum back,
we get fields, and some additional things. And
if we go into the fields itself, we see there's
a lot more information, if you can make out like
here, it says merchant phone number, form field
label value, and there's a number 512707.
So for these things here, like the receipts,
if we can just find the API quickly here,
it has predefined fields. I'm not sure.
Yeah, business card, etc. Like
if we just type in merchant,
I'm just trying to see if there's a big old list
here. It's not really showing us a full list. But
these are predefined things that are returned,
right? So they've defined those. Maybe it's over
here. There we go. So these are the predefined
ones that extracts out. So we have receipt, type,
merchant name, etc, etc. And so if we go back to
here, you can see I have a field called merchant
name. So we get there it says Alamo Drafthouse
cinema, let's say we want to try to get that
balance. Maybe we can try to figure out which
one it is. I never ran this myself when I made
it. So we'll see what it is. But here it has total
price. What's interesting is that these, this is a
space. So it's a kind of unusual, you think it'd
be together, but let's see if that works. Okay,
doesn't like that. Maybe that's just a typo on
their part. Okay, so we get none. Let's try price.
See what it picks up? Nope, nothing.
We know that the phone numbers there.
So we'll give the phone number.
There we go. So you know, it's an OK service.
But, you know, you know, your your mileage will
vary based on what you do there. Maybe we could
try total, because that makes more sense, right?
Ah,
yeah, there we go. Okay, great. So
yeah, it is pulling out the information.
And so that's pretty much all you need
to know about that service there. Okay.
Let's take a look at some of our OCR capabilities
here. I believe that's in computer vision. So
we'll go ahead and open that up. At the top here
we'll install computer vision as we did before,
very similar to the other computer
vision tasks, but this time we have
a couple of ones here that I'll explain that as we
go through here. We'll load our keys. We'll Do our
credentials will load the client. Okay, and then
we have this function here called printed text.
So what this function is going to do is it's
going to print out the results of whatever text it
processes. Okay, so the idea is that we're going
to feed in an image, and it's going to give us
back out the text for the image. So we'll run this
function. And I have two different images, because
I actually ran it on the first one, and the
results were terrible. And so I got a second image
and it was a bit better. Okay, so we'll go ahead
and run this, it's going to show us the image.
Okay, and so this is the photo, it was supposed
to extract out Star Trek The Next Generation, but
because of the artifacts and size of the image,
we get back, not English, okay. So you know,
maybe a high resolution image, it would have a
better a better time there. But that is what we
got back. Okay. So let's go take a look at our
second image and see how it did. And this one,
I'm surprised that I actually extracts out a
lot more information, you can see realize a
hard time with the Star Trek font, but we get Deep
Space Nine, nine, a visitor tells all life death,
some errors here, so it's not perfect. But you
know, you can see that it does something here.
Now there is the iOS. This is like for OCR, where
we have like first very simple images and texts.
This is where we use the recognized printed text
in stream. But if we're doing this for larger
amounts of text, and we want to do this, want this
analyzed a synchronously, then we want to use the
read API, and it's a little bit more involved. So
what we'll do here is load a different image. And
this is a script, we'll look at the image here
in a moment. But here we read in stream, and we
create these operations. Okay. And what it will
do is it will asynchronous asynchronously send
all the information over. Okay. So I think this
is supposed to be results here. Minor typo. And
we will go ahead and give that a run. Okay, so
here you can see it's extract out the image if
we want to see this image. I thought I thought
I showed this image here, but I guess I don't.
Yes, this plot image here to show
us the image. path. It's up here.
It doesn't want to show us it's funny because
this one up here is showing us No problem, right?
Um, well, I can just show you
the image. It's not a big deal.
But I'm not sure why it's not showing up
here today. So if we go to your assets here,
I go to OCR. I'm just gonna open this up. Hope
it's opening up in Photoshop. And so this is what
it's transcribing. Okay, so this is a thing.
This is like a guide to Star Trek where they
talk about like, you know, what, what makes
Star Trek Star Trek. So just looking here, it's
actually pretty darn good. Okay. But like read
API is a lot more efficient, because it can work
asynchronously. And so when you have a lot
of texts, that's what you want to do, okay?
Like it's feeding in each individual line, right,
so that it can be more effective that way. So
let's go look at some handwritten stuff. So just
in case the image doesn't pop up, we'll go ahead
and open this one. And so this is a handwritten
note that William Shatner wrote to a fan of Star
Trek, and it's basically incomprehensible.
I don't know if you can read that here. But
see, was very something he was something
hospital and healthy was something he was
something I can't even read it. Okay, so
let's see what the machine thinks here.
And it says image path, it's called path. Let's
just change that out. We hadn't run that. Run that
there. And we'll go ahead and run it. And here we
got the image. So poner us very sick, he was the
hospital his BD was, etc. Beat nobody lost. His
family knew Captain halden. So reads better than
how I could read it, honestly, like it is. It's
really hard, right? Like, if you looked at this,
like, that looks like difficult was bt healthy.
I could see why it's guessing like that,
right? dying. It's like that looks like dying
to me. You don't I mean, so it's just poorly
hand handwritten, but I mean, it's pretty
good for what it is. So yeah, there you go.
Alright, so let's take a look at another
cognitive service here. And this one is text
analysis. And so what we'll do is install
the Azure cognitive services, language text
analytics here. So go ahead and hit run. Alright,
and once that's installed, this one actually is
using the cognitive services credential, so it's a
little bit more standard with our other ones here.
We'll go ahead and run that there. We'll make our
credentials low clients. And this one, what we're
going to do is try to determine sentiment and
understand why people like a particular movie
or not. So I've loaded a bunch of reviews, they
are again, I can show you the data, if it helps.
And so I'm just trying to find my right
folder here. And so if we go back,
look, our movie reviews, here's like a review,
someone wrote, first contact just works. It's
works as a rousing chapter in the Star Trek to
lesser set works as a mainstream entertainment.
So different reviews for Star Trek First Contact,
which was a very popular movie back in the day. So
what we'll do is as we will load the reviews,
so it's just iterating through the text files
and showing us what the reviews are. so here we
can see all the written text had a lot of trouble
getting the last one to display, but it does
get loaded in. And so here we're using the the
text analysis to show us key phrases because
maybe that would give us an indicator.
And so that's the object back but maybe that'll
give us an indicator as to like what people are
saying as important things so here we see
Borg ship, enterprise smaller ship escapes,
neutral zone travels, contact damage, co writer
beautiful mind sophisticate science fiction,
best whales, Leonard Nimoy. Okay. wealth of
unrealized potential filmmaker john Franks.
Okay, so very interesting stuff as here Borg
ship again, you've seen Borg ship a lot.
So that is kind of key phrases, let's go get Cust
or customer sentiment or how people felt about it,
do they like it or not. And so here, we just
call sentiment. And what we'll do is if it's
above five, then it's positive, and it's below
five, then it's a negative review. I think most
people thought it was very good film. So this one
says it's pretty low nine. So let's go take a look
at that one. It wasn't actually showing rendered
there. So maybe we'll have to open it up manually.
See if that's actually accurate,
it's empty. So there you go.
I guess we had a blank one in there. I must have
forgot to paste it in. But that's okay. That's a
good indicator that, you know, that's what happens
if you don't have it. So let's look at number one,
then, which is actually this one is nine, this
is 04. This one here is eight. So open up eight.
When the board launch on Earth, the enterprise
is sent to the neutral zone, etc, etc. However,
smaller ship escapes traveled of enterprise falls
back. Meanwhile, the survivors, so like this is a
synopsis. It doesn't say whether they like it, or
they don't. But it was before, I guess. So there's
nothing positive about it. Right? If we were
looking at one that was this one's pretty low,
which is no, no, it's not. It's one. So it
seems like this person probably really liked it.
Or no, I guess that's actually pretty low. Because
it's one it's not nine, nine is very high. Let's
take a look at this one. Review number two. If
we go up here, the dog has improved the Sorry,
I'm going to turn the show but there's a wealth
of unrealized potential. So that's a fair
one saying that maybe they don't like it as
much. I don't know if they give it two stars,
right, we could probably actually correlate
it with the actual results, because I did get
these off of IMDb and Rotten Tomatoes. But
yeah, there you go. That is text analysis.
Alright, so now we're on to q&a maker. And
so we're not going to need to do anything
programmatically, because q&a maker is all about
no code or low code to build out a questions and
answers bot service. So what we'll do is
go all the way up to here. And I want you
to type in Q and maker.ai. Because as far as
I'm aware of so accessible through the portal,
sometimes you can find these things. Again, if we
go to the marketplace. I'm just curious. I could
just take a look here really quickly. Whenever
it decides to log us in here. Okay, great. So
I'll go over to marketplace. And probably we
type in q&a. Maybe we do something here q&a.
Yep. So we go here. Give it a second here.
Seems like Azure is a little bit slow right now.
It's usually very fast. But
you know, the service varies.
Well, it's not loading for me right now.
But that's okay, because we're not going
to do it that way. Anyway. So you can go to q&a
maker.ai. And what I want you to do is go all
at the top of the right corner, and we'll hit
sign in. And what we'll be doing is connecting
via our single sign on with our account, so
it already knows I have an account there.
I'm gonna give it a moment here. And I'm
going to go ahead and just give it a second.
There we go. So it says I don't have any knowledge
base, which is true. So let's go ahead and create
ourselves a new knowledge base. And here we have
the option Between stable and preview, I'm going
to stick with stable because I don't know what's
in preview. I'm pretty happy with that. So we
need to connect q&a service q&a service to our
knowledge base. And so back over here in Azure,
actually, I guess we do have to make one now
that I remember, we actually have to create
a q&a maker service. So I'll go down here and put
this under my cog services will say my queue at a
queue and a service might complain about the
name. Yep, so I'll just put some numbers here.
We will pick a free tier sounds good, I'll go free
what I actually get the option, that's what I will
choose. Down below, we'll choose free again, USB
sounds great to me, it generates out the name,
it's the same name as here. So that's fine. We
don't need App Insights, I'm going to leave it
enabled, because I think it changes the standard
or zero when you do not have an enabled unusually.
And so we will create our q&a maker service, give
it a moment here. And it says I remember it will
say like, even if you try it, it might have to
wait 10 minutes for it to create the service.
So even though even after it's provisioned, it
will take some time. So what we should do is
prepare our doc because it can take in a variety
different files. I just want to show you here
that the q&a that a whole paper here formatting
the guidelines. And basically it's pretty smart
about knowing where headings and answers is. So
for unstructured data, we just have a heading,
and we have some text, let's write some things
in here that we can think of. Since we're all
about certification, we should write some stuff
here. So how many AWS certifications are there?
I believe right now, there are 11.
eight of us certifications. Okay.
And maybe if we use our headings here, this
would probably be a good idea here. Yeah.
Okay. Another one could be how many fundamental
Azure certifications are there. And
we'll give this a heading. And we'll say
there are three as your I think there's
three. There's other ones, right, like pirate
power platform and stuff. But just being Azure
specific. There are three as your fundamental
certifications, certification, so we
have the DP 900, the AI 900. The az
900. I guess there's four, there's the
SC 900. Right. So there are four. Okay.
We'll say which is the hardest. Azure
Azure Association certification.
And what we'll say here is, I think, I mean, it's
my is my opinion is it's the Azure administrator,
had some background noise there. That's
why I was a bit pausing there. But the
Azure minister, az 104, I would say
that's the hardest, which is harder.
The AWS or Azure certifications,
I'd say Azure certifications
are harder. Because they check exact steps
for implementation where AWS focuses on
concepts. Okay, so we have a bit of a
knowledge base here. So I'll save it.
And assuming that this is ready, because we
did a little bit time to put this together.
We'll go back to q&a, hit a refresh here. Give
it a moment, drop it down, choose our service.
And notice here that we have chitchat extraction
and only extraction we're going to do to chat.
I will say my or this is the reference
can be changed any time this would be like
a certification q&a. So here, we want
to populate. So we'll go to files here,
I'm going to go to my desktop.
And here it is. I'll open it.
We will choose professional town. Go ahead and
create that. And so I'll see you back here in a
moment. Alright, so after waiting a short little
time here, it loaded in our data. So you can see
that it figured out which is the question which
is the answer and also has a bunch of default.
So Here if somebody was at something very silly,
like, can you cry, I'll say I don't have a body.
It has a lot of information pre loaded for us,
which is really nice. Why don't we go ahead and
test this? We could go and say, we'll go here
and then we'll write in, say, like, hello.
Say boring. This is good
morning. Okay, so we'll say,
how many certifications are there? We didn't
say AWS, but let's just see what happens.
So to kind of infer even though we didn't say
AWS in particular, so I noticed that there's
AWS and Azure, so how many fundamental Azure
certifications, things like that, and so chose
AWS. So it's not like the perfect service, but
it's pretty good. I wonder what would happen if we
placed in one that's like Azure, I don't know how
many Azure certs there are, we'll just say like,
there's 1112, I can't ever remember, they're
always adding more. But I want to close this here.
There we go. So let's just go add a new key pair
here. And we'll say, how many Azure certification
are there, I should have said certifications, I'll
probably just set one moment. So there, there are
12, Azure certifications. Who knows how many they
have, they have like 14 or something, say like,
between 11 and 14. They just added they just
updated them too frequently. I can't keep track.
So we'll go here and we'll
just say certifications.
And we will save and retrain. So
we'll just wait here a moment.
Great. And so now we'll go ahead and test this
again. So we'll say how many certifications
are there?
I see it's pulling the first
answer. If I say Azure,
let's just see if it gets the right one here.
How many Azure certifications are there?
Okay, so, you know, maybe you'd have to
say you'd have to have a generic one for
that match. So if we go back here, and we
say, how many certifications are there?
You say, you know, like, which certification?
Which cert cloud service provider.
Here we got AWS Azure. Follow prompt, you
can use guides through conversational flow
prompts are used to link q&a pairs and can be
displayed. I haven't used this yet. But I mean,
it sounds like something that's pretty good.
Because there is multi turn into so the idea
is that if you had to go through multiple steps,
you could absolutely do that. We've tried a little
bit here, fall prompt you can use to guide us to
convert props are used to link q&a pairs together,
text or button for suggested action. Oh, okay,
so maybe we would just do like AWS link to q&a.
And then so search an existing q&a or create a new
one. So let's say like, how many eight of us, oh,
okay, we're typing in context, this follows up
will not be understood out of the context flow.
Sure. Because it should be within context, right.
And here, we can do another one we say like
Azure will say, how many Azure
contacts only. Whoops, that
got away from me there.
We'll save that. And what
we'll do is save and train.
Go back here. And we'll say, how
many certifications are there?
Enter. So we have to choose AWS. So there we
go. So we got something that works pretty good
there. Since I'm happy with it, we can go ahead
and go and publish that. So let's say publish.
And now that it's published,
we could use postman or curl to
trigger it. But what I want to do is create
a bot because with Azure bot services,
then we can actually utilize it with other
integrations right. It's great way to
use your bot or to actually host your bot. So
we'll go over here and link it over. If you don't
click it, it doesn't pre loaded in so it's kind
of a pain. If you lose Got to go back there and
click it again. But let's just say certification.
que en de. And we will look through here. So I'm
going to go with free premium messages, 10k
1k Premium message units, messages, I'm kind
of confused by the pricing. But f0 using means
free. So that's what I'm gonna go for that SDK or
no GS, I'm gonna use no GS now that we're gonna do
anything there with it. Go ahead and create that.
And I don't think this takes
too long. We'll see here.
Just go ahead and click on that there. I'll
just wait here a bit. I'll see you back here
in a moment. All right. So after waiting, I
don't know about five minutes there. It looks
like our bots services deployed, we'll go to that
resource there. You can download the bot source
code. Actually, I never did this. So I don't know
what it looks like. So be curious to see this.
Just to see what the code is. I assume that
because we chose chose no GS, it would give
us that is the default there. So download
this code as you're creating the source IP.
Not sure how long this takes. Maybe regretting
clicking on that. But what we'll do is we'll
go in the left hand side here to channels
because I just want to show here. Yeah, that
didn't download. We'll try it here in a second.
But what we'll do is we'll go back up profile.
unspecified bar we talked about.
Yeah, maybe it needs some time.
So you know, maybe we'll just give the bot
a little bit of time here. I'm not sure why
it's giving us a hard time because this bot is
definitely deployed. If we go over to our bots,
right. bot services, it is here. Sometimes
there's like latency, you know, with
Azure. Oh, there we go. Okay, see works now. Fine,
right. And so I want to show you that there's
different channels and these are just easy ways
to integrate your bot and different services. So
whether you want her to use it with Alexa GroupMe,
Skype telephony, Twilio Skype for Business,
apparently they don't have that anymore.
Because they get small teams now, right. keek,
which I don't know, people still use that Slack,
which that discord, telegram Facebook, email.
That's kind of cool. But teams teams is
a really good one. I use teams. There's a
direct line channel, I don't know what that means.
And there's web chat, which is just having like an
embed code. So if we go over, we can go and test
it over here to start testing our web chat. And
so it's the same thing as before, we just say
things like, how many certifications are there?
Azure, and get a clear answer back. We'll
go back up to our overview. Let's try see
if we can download that code. Again. I
was kind of curious what that looks like.
Yes, it will download
a lot of code a.
There we go. So now we can hit download. And
so there is the code, I'm going to go ahead
and open that up. So yeah, I guess when we
chose JavaScript, that made a lot more sense.
Let's give it a little peek here. I'm just going
to drop this on my desktop here. So just to make
a new folder here and call this bot code. Okay,
I know you can't see what I'm doing here. But
let's go here, and gret, double click into
here, and then just drag that code on him.
And then what we can do is open this up
in VS code, I should have VS code running
somewhere around here. I'm gonna go ahead
and open that off screen here. I'll just
show you my screen in a moment. Say show code,
oops, File, Open Folder. botcon code, okay.
And all the way back here. And so we got a lot
of code here. never looked at this before. But
you know, I'm a pretty good programmers.
So it's not too hard for me to understand.
So it's like your API request, things
like that. I guess it would just be like,
if you needed to integrate into your application,
then it kind of shows you all the code. They're
just trying to see our dialogue
choices. Nothing super exciting.
Okay, you know what I go and make the Was
it the AI are the 100 whatever the data
scientists courses, I'm sure I'll be a lot
more thorough here. But I'm just curious as
to what that looks like. Now, if we wanted
to have an easy integration, we can get an
embedding code for this. So if we go back to
our channels, I believe we can go and edit.
Ah, yeah. So here we have a code. So
what I'll do is go back to Jupiter labs,
I'm just going to go make a new empty
notebook. So let's go up here and say notebook.
And this can be for our q&a. Doesn't really
matter what Colonel, say cute and a maker. Just
show like, if you wanted a very, very simple way
of integrating your bot, we would go back over to
wherever it is here. Here, we are
going to go ahead and copy this iframe.
I think it's percentage percentage
HTML. So it treats this cell as HTML.
And I don't have any HTML to render. So we
will place that in there. And notice we have
to replace our secret key. So I will go back here
and I will show my key and we will copy that.
And we will paste that key in here.
And then we'll run this. And I can type
in here. Where am I? just silly things.
Who are you? How many Azure certifications? Are
there? Well, I wonder if I just leave the are
there off? Let's see if it's figures it out. Okay,
cool. So yeah, I mean, that's pretty much it with
q&a maker. So yeah, that's great. So I think we're
done here. And we can move on to checking out
Louis or Liu is learning understanding
to make a more robust bot, okay.
Alright, so we are on to our last cognitive
service. And this one is going to be
Louis or Luis, depending on how you'd like to say
it. It's Li s, which is language understanding. So
you type in L ui s.ai. And that's going to bring
us up to this external websites. So part of Azure
just has its own domain. And so here, we'll choose
our subscription. And we have no author authoring
source. So I guess we'll have to go ahead and
create one ourselves. So get down here, and we
will choose my cognitive services as your resource
name. So my off service or my cognitive service,
great new cognitive service
account, but we already have one,
so I don't want to make another one.
Right, it should show up here, right?
Or valid in the author authoring region.
So it's possible that we're just in the
incorrect region. So we might end up creating
two of these. And that's totally fine. I don't
care. It's as long as we get this work in here,
because we're gonna delete everything, get the
end anyway. And so just say, my cog service, too.
And we'll say West us because I think that maybe
we didn't choose one of these regions. Let's
go double check. If we go back to our portal,
just the limitations of the service, right. So
we'll go to my cog services here. I just want to
go cognitive services. So just want to see where
this is deployed. And this is in us, West us.
Yeah, so I don't know why it's not showing up
there. But whatever. If that sort of wants,
we'll give it what it wants, okay. shouldn't give
us that much trouble, but pay, that's how it goes.
And so we have an authorized authoring
service, I'm gonna refresh here and see if
it added a second one, it didn't. So all right.
That's fine. So we'll just say, my sample bot
will use English as our culture. If
nothing shows up here, don't worry,
you can choose it later on. I remember the
first time I did this, it didn't show up.
And so now we have my cog service, my
custom vision service, we want cog service.
So anyway, it tells us about schema, like how you
make a schema animates talking about like body,
action, intent, and example utterance, but we're
just gonna set up something very simple here. So
we're gonna create or attend, the one that we
always see is flight booking. So I'll go here,
do that. And what we want to do is write an under
and so like, book, me a flight to Toronto. Okay.
So if someone were to type that in, then the idea
was it would return back the intent this value and
metadata around it. And we could programmatically
provide code, right? So what we need is identity
identities and we can actually just click here and
make one here. So enter name identity, and we'll
just call this location. Okay. Here we have option
machine learned and list if you flip between it.
This is like a magic Have a ticket order
and you have these values that can change,
or you just have a value that always stays
the same like lists. So that's our airport.
That makes sense, we'll do that. If we
go over to entities, we can see it here.
Alright, so nothing super exciting there. But
what I want to show you is if we go ahead, and we
should probably add, fight booking should be about
book flight. flight booking, flight booking. Okay,
so we'll go ahead and I know there's only
one, we'll go ahead and train our model.
Because we don't need to know tons, right,
we cover a lot in the lecture content
to build a complex bot is
more for the associate level.
But now what we can do is go ahead and test
this and we'll say, book me a flight to Seattle.
Okay, and notice here it says
book flight, we can go inspect it,
and we get some additional data. So top scoring,
so it says how likely that was the intent.
Okay, so you get kind of an idea there, there's
additional things here, it doesn't really matter.
We'll go back here, and we will
go ahead and publish our model.
So we can put it into a production slot, you can
see we have sentiment analysis, speech, priming,
we don't care about either of those things. We
can go and see where our endpoint is. And so
now we have an endpoint that we can work
with. So yeah, I mean, that's pretty much
all you really need to learn about Louis. But I
think we're all done for cognitive services. So
we're going to keep around our notebook,
because we're going to still use your Jupyter
Notebook for some other things. But what
I want you to do is make your way over to
your resource groups. Because if you've been
pretty clean, it's all within here, we'll just
take a look here. So we have our q&a. All of
our stuff here, I'm just making sure it's all
there. And so I'm just gonna go ahead and delete
this resource group. And that should wipe away
everything, okay? For the cognitive services
part. Alright, so we're all good here. And I'm
just going to go off, and I'll leave this open,
because it's always a pain to get back to it,
reopen it, but let's make our way back to
the home here and the Azure Machine Learning
Studio. And now we can actually explore
building up machine learning pipelines.
Okay, so we are on to the ML kit, follow along
here. So we're going to learn how to build some
pipelines, the first i think is the easiest will
be auto automated ml are also known as auto ml.
The idea here is it's going to just build up the
entire pipeline for us. So we don't have to do any
thinking we just say what kind of model we want
to run and have it to make a prediction. So what
we'll do is a new automated ml, and we're going
to need a data set. So I don't have one. But the
nice thing is they have these open datasets. So if
you click here, you'll see there is a bunch here.
And a lot of these you'll come across quite often,
not just on Azure, but other places like this
diabetes one, I seen it like everywhere, okay. And
so like, if we just go click here, and maybe we
can read a bit more here. So diabetes data, set
422 samples with 10 features, ideal for getting
started with machine learning algorithms. It's
one of the popular psychic learn toy data sets.
It's probably where I've seen it before, though
it's not showing up there. You scroll on down,
you can see the data sets available as your
notebooks data, bricks and Azure synapse.
The thing is, we have these values of age, sex,
BMI, BP and y is trying to make a prediction,
it's trying to say, what's the likelihood of you
having diabetes or not? And so it's not boolean
value. So it's not a binary classifier. It's
kind of on a like you, would you be doing binary
classifications? classification, say, do you have
diabetes, or you can make a prediction to say,
what's the likelihood or this value if you gave
another value in there. But anyway, this is the
predicted value, a lot of times this is x, so
everything here is x. And this is considered y,
the actual prediction. So sometimes it's why
and sometimes it's actually named what it is.
But that's just what it is here. So we'll close
that off. And so we'll choose the diabetes set.
And it will be data set one. And so it will worry
about feedback later. So we'll click on sample
diabetes will hit next. And here's going to try
to figure out what kind of model that we want. We
have to create a new experiments a container to
run the model in so I'll just say, diabetes. My
diabetes, it sounds a bit odd, but that's what
it is the target call and we want to predict
is seeing the train to predict is the why it's
usually the why we don't have a compute cluster.
So I'll go ahead and create a new compute. We
have dedicated or low priority. Technically,
we It is low priority, but I just want this done
low priority, but don't forget to compute nodes,
your job may be preempted. I'm gonna
say with dedicated for the time being,
we're gonna stick with CPU. If we go with
this, it does take about an hour to run.
So I ran this ticket about an hour. So if you
don't mind, it's only going to cost you 15 cents.
But if you want this done a lot sooner, I'm going
to try to do something a little bit more powerful.
So just trying to decide here,
because if it only takes an hour,
I might run it on something more powerful, that's
90 cents, that might be overkill, because it's not
really deep learning. It's just a statistical,
statistical stuff. So true and large data set,
I wouldn't say it's large real time
inference, other latency sensitive ones.
How Bode? Why is this one, I'm just looking
here, cuz this one's 29 cents, this one's more
expensive. But it has 32 gigabytes of RAM. This
was 28 Oh, 14 gigabytes of RAM and storage. So
this one's our highest in the tier, again, you
can choose this one, you just have to wait a lot
longer, I just want to see if it finishes a lot
faster, okay, without having to go to the GPU
level. So I don't think GPU is gonna help too much
here. The computer name is my diabetes machine.
minimum number of nodes. You want to provision if
you want dedicated nodes to set the count here,
maximum. I guess I just want one node, right?
We will go ahead and oops, complete
name must be 216 characters long.
What is it? Is it too long? Okay, there we go.
We'll give it a moment here. Yeah, it's
gonna spin up the cluster. So it does take
a little bit time to start this. So I'll
see you back here when this is done. Okay.
Great. So after a short little wait there, it
looks like our cluster is running. If we double
check here, we can go to compute, I believe that
shows up under here under the compute clusters.
So there it is, this is slightly different.
This one shows you applications and this one
is just size, etc. and click in here see nodes
and runtimes. We'll go make our way back here.
And we'll go ahead and hit next. And notice that
I think it actually will select what it generally
does, it'll look at your prediction value,
maybe sample a bit of it and say, okay, you
probably want a regression thing. So to predict
a continuous numeric values. So the thing is,
is that if it was a label, like text, or if it
was just zero in one, it probably would choose
classification, because it's, you saw our y value
is like a number that was all over the place.
It thinks it's regression. So I think that's a
good indicator there. So let's go with regression.
You know, but you might want it as a binary
classifier, but it's another story there.
So it's, as soon as we created it just started,
it didn't give us the option to say, hey,
I want to start running it. Notice on here, it's
going to do feature iteration. So that means it's
automatically gonna select out features for us,
which is what we wanted to do. It's set up to do
regression, we have some configuration
here. So training time is three hours,
doesn't mean it's gonna train for three hours.
But that's, I guess it's time out for it.
You could set a metric score threshold, so it
has to meet at least this to be successful. If
it's not going to do it probably would quit out
early crossmember valve or cross validation, just
make sure the data is good. You can see blocked
algorithms. So TensorFlow dnn, TensorFlow linear
regression, if it was using dnn. So deep learning
neural network, I probably would have chosen the
GPU to see if it would go faster. Look at the
primary metric gets normalized root square
root mean square error, sometimes on the exam
will actually ask you like, what's the primary
metric for this thing. So it's good to take a
look and see what they actually use. For that,
I'll probably be sure to highlight that
stuff in the actual lecture content.
But this will take some time to run. We have
data guard rails, it will actually not populate,
I guess until we've ran it. So we'll just let it
run. And I'll see you back here when it's done.
Okay. All right. So after a very, very, very long
wait, our auto ml job is done. It took 60 minutes.
Using a larger instance, didn't save me any time.
I don't know if maybe if I ran a GPU instance,
it would be a lot faster. I'd be very curious
to try that out. But not something for this
certification course. So we go into here and yeah,
the cheaper instance was the same amount of time.
So it probably just needs GPUs. It really depends
on the type of models it's running. So we have
a bunch of different algorithms in here. It ran
about 42 different models. I thought of like last
time I ran it, I saw a lot more but you can see
there's all kinds of models that it's running and
then it's going to choose the top candidates.
So it shows Voting ensemble. So ensemble is
we don't cover really in the course because it
gets too much into ml, but ensemble is when you
actually use two different weaker models and
combine the results in order to make a more
powerful ml model. Okay. So here, we'll get some
explanation. I tried this before, and I didn't get
really good information. So if we go here, like
I don't have anything under model performance. So
this tab requires a ray of predicted values from
the model to be supplied. We didn't supply any,
so we don't get any Data Explorer. So select a
cohort of the data, that all the data is what we
have here. So like, here, we were seeing age.
And I guess it's just giving us an indicator
about the age information. Use the slider
to show just descending feature importance,
select up to three cohorts to see the
feature important side by side. Okay.
So I guess, s five and BMI. I don't know what s
five is, we'd have to look up the dataset. BMI is
your body mass index. So that's a clear indicator
as to what affects whether you have diabetes or
not. So that makes sense. age doesn't seem to
be a huge factor, which is kind of interesting.
Individual feature importance, we can go here
and just kind of like narrow in and say, Okay,
well, why is this outlier
over here? And they're like
age 79. Right? So it's kind of interesting to
see that information. So it does give you some x
explanation as to, you know,
why things are why they are.
Over here, we have a little bit
more different data. This is kind
of interesting model performance. I don't
know what I'm looking at, but like here,
it's over a mean squared. So it's that
mean squared calculation there again? Okay.
Yeah, it's something right. But
anyway, the point is, is that,
that we finally get metrics, I guess we always
had to click there, because that makes more sense.
So yeah, there's more values here. Sure. data
transformation, sorts of data processing feature
engineering scaling techniques, and machine
learning algorithm, auto ml. So you know,
if you were a real data scientists,
all this stuff would make sense to you.
I think just with time, it'll, it'll make sense.
But even at this point, I'm not sure. And I don't
care about the model, right? If you're building
something for real, I'm sure the information
becomes a lot more valuable. So this model is
done. And the idea is that we can deploy oops,
if we go back to the actual models, because we
actually went into the map. So we go back to the
auto ml here. I think you can deploy any
model that you'd like. So you can go here
and deploy this, like if you prefer a
different model, you could deploy it.
If we go into data guard rails, we kind of skipped
over that this is a way does automatic feature
rotation, so it's extracting the feature,
so it handles the splitting, how it handles
missing features. Hi, Carbonell nowadays, like
if you have too much data, it might have to do
dimensionality reduction. So that's just saying
like, hey, if this is a problem, maybe we would
do some pre processing or stuff to make it
easier to work with the data. So if we're
happy with this, we can go ahead and deploy it.
So let's say deploy, just say infer my diabetes.
Here we have aka s and E's. Azure Container
instance. Let's do Azure Kubernetes
Kubernetes services because we did the other one
here. Say diabetes. Broad maybe a Ks diabetes.
Oh, compute name, sorry. One of the
inference ones. Okay. So in order to
deploy this, we would have to create our
pipeline. I'm not sure if I have enough
in my quota here, but let's go give it a go. So
I think what it's wanting is one of these here.
I think we'd want this wherever
we are, right? I'm not sure
where we are. If This Is Us, east or
west here. Let's go check. Studio.
Azure Machine Learning
hits us. No, I never did this when I was. I
just use use the Azure Container instance. But
I'm just curious here. say next. My diabetes
prod,
we will need to choose some nodes.
The number of nodes multiplied by the virtual
machines, number of cores must be greater or equal
to 12. Okay? Now again, if you're not confident,
like every concern about costs, you can just
again, watch, you don't have to do right.
This is again, a fundamental certification,
it's not super important to get all
the hands on experience yourself.
But I'm just trying to explore this so
we can see, right, because I don't care
about costs. It's not a big deal to me, on
my machine here, so probably I don't have
simple must use a vn SKU with more than
two cores and four gigabytes. Well,
what did I choose? Did I not choose
the right one? We'll try this again.
Oh, I chose three. Yeah, that's fair. What
did it want 12 cores set before I think.
Invalid parameters, more details? Because
that already exists based on that name a two.
It's given us all this trouble I this one
will go ahead and delete you think like,
it wouldn't matter. Like I wouldn't
have to delete it out. But that's fine.
This one failed. Now, what's the problem? quota
exceeded so I can't do it. Because I don't I'd
have to go make a support request increase it. So
it's not a real big deal. I guess what we could do
is instead of doing it on a KS, we just deploy
to container instance, if it will let us
notice I don't have to fill anything
additional. It'll just deploy I think.
Great. And so I guess we'll let that deploy. And
I'll see you back here in a bit. Okay. Alright,
so I'm back here, checking it out on my are
checking up on my auto ml here. So if we go
over to compute, we go to inference clusters,
we don't have anything under there if we go
over to our experiments under our diabetes
here. Because we did choose to deploy the model.
Right, we clicked deploy. So it should have
created an ACI instance, let's make our way
over to the portal. The reason why it might not
be showing up is because I'm just running out
of compute. Because again, it's a quota thing.
It's not a big deal for us to get a deploy. So
we're gonna do anything with it. But yeah, so
we can see that we have a container over here,
and it's running. So we must be able to see
if we go to endpoints here. Here it is. Right,
I was under models as my problem. So
pipeline endpoints, that would be something
I think that if we had deployed our designer, I
thought we would have thought under there. But
here we have our binary pipeline, or our diabetes,
prod pipelines. So if we wanted to like test data,
you know, we could pass stuff in here. I think if
we wanted to try to just like see this in action,
I'm not sure if it's going to work, but we'll
give it a go. So if we go into our sample
diabetes data set, and we just explore some of
the data, we should be able to kind of select
out some values, because I don't know what
these values mean. So let's just say like 36
oops, 36. But we already know that BMI is the
major factor here. Sex is either one or two.
So we'll say to BMI, we'll say 25.3. The BP
will be 83 or whatever. Oops. 83. Here. s 160.
s two can be 99.63 4545 and 5.10.
The only we're running out of metrics here
82. What do I doesn't give us all them? Oh,
I guess it does. It's up to six. Okay, so
let's go ahead and test that. So we get and
we got a result back 168. So that is auto ml all
complete there for you. Yeah, so there you go.
Alright, so let's take a look here at the visual
designer because it's a great
way to get started very easily.
With If you don't know what you're doing, and you
want something a little bit more advanced than
auto ml and have some customization, it's great to
start with one of these samples. So let's go ahead
and expand and see what we have here. We have
binary classification with custom Python script,
tune parameters for binary classification,
multi class, multi class classification,
so letter recognition, text classification, all
sorts of things. Usually binary classification,
classification is pretty easy. I'm looking for one
that is pretty darn simple. Let's go take a look
here. So this says the sample shows how to filter
based feature selection to selection features.
binary classification, so how to predictors
related to customer relationships using binary
classes, how to handle imbalanced datasets,
using smote. And modules, I'm not really
worried about balancing customized Python script
to perform cost sensitive, binary classification,
tune parameters. So you tune model parameters,
best models during the training process, let's
go with this one. This one seems okay to me.
And so what you can see here is that it's using
a sample data set, I believe, I think this is a
sample. And if you wanted to see all of them, you
can literally drag them out here and do things
with them. I haven't actually built one end to end
yet for for this again, I don't think it's like
super important for this level of exam. But this
just shows you that there's a pre built one, if
you've started to get the handle of ml, you know,
the full pipeline. This isn't too confusing. So
at the beginning, here, we have our classification
data. And then what it's going to do is say
select columns in the data set. So it says
exclude column names work class, occupation,
native country, so it's doing some pre processing
there, excluding that data might be interesting
to go look at that data set. So if we go over
to our data sets tab, it should show up here,
I believe. Maybe because we haven't committed
or submitted this, we can't see that data set
yet. But we'll look at it for a moment that we
want to clean our data. So here's saying clean
all the columns. So custom substitution value,
see if we can see what it's substituting out.
It's not saying what's so clean missing data. So
I'm not sure what it's cleaning out there. But
because that would suggest that it's
using some kind of custom script,
I'm not sure where it is. But that's okay. We have
split data, pretty common to split your data. So
you would have a training and test data set,
it's usually really good to randomize it. So you
want to randomize it, then split it. And that's,
that's just so you get better results, that it has
model hyper parameter tuning. So the idea is
that it's going to use ml to figure out the
the best parameters for tuning. Over here we have
the two classes decision tree where it's going to
do some work there, it's going to score our model,
and then it's going to evaluate our model and see
if it's successful. So this is all set up to go.
So all we're going to do is go to the top here,
this is setting wheel here. And we need to choose
some type of compute. So I'm going to go here,
and we have this one here. But I'm going
to go create, as for my, my diabetes one,
I'm going to go ahead and make a new one. And
we're going to say, recommend using a predefined
configuration to quickly set compute training.
This one looks okay, I don't know if it needs two
nodes. But I guess we can do this one. So we'll
just say binary was just like binary pipeline.
Okay. Say save, save. Hopefully, it's making
good suggestion. And we will have to wait for
that to spin up. It's going to take a little bit
of time. Okay, so I'll see you back here in a
moment. Alright, so I got a little message saying
that that is ready. So what we can do, I think it
was here, my notebook instance. Now that's not
it, but I definitely saw a pop up on my screen.
You might have saw it to you that to be paying
close attention for that. But if you go over,
it says that it's it's ready to go. So what I'm
going to do is make my way back over here, we're
going to select our compute, there is our binary
pipeline, I'm going to select that. And there are
some other options, we're not gonna fiddle around
with that, we're going to go ahead and hit submit.
So we need a new experiment. So I'm going to
just say, binary pipeline. We'll hit submit.
Okay, and so this is now running. So after a
little while here, we're going to start seeing
these go green. So this is not started. We'll
give it a moment here. So we can see some kind
of animation. And there it goes, it's off to the
races. There's not much to do here. This is going
to take a while. I don't know, I have never ran
this one in particular. So I don't know if it's
an hour or 30 minutes. So I'll see you back when
it's done running. But yeah, it's it's not that
fun to watch, but it's cool that you get a visual
illustration. So I'll see you back in a bit.
I just wanted to peek in here and take a look at
how it's progressing here and you can see it's
still going and it's just cleaning the data,
it's still not done. I'm not sure how long
this has been running for if we go over to our
experiments, and we go into our binary pipeline,
and we look at the runtime, we're about eight
minutes in, and it hasn't done a whole lot. So
it's still cleaning the data, I would have thought
a bit, it'd be a little bit faster. I'm kind of
used to using like AWS, and it goes, sage makers.
This doesn't usually take this long. But I mean,
it's nice that it's, it's going here. But yeah,
so we're almost out of the pre processing phase.
And we'll be on to the model tuning, okay.
Alright, so after waiting a little while, it looks
like our pipeline is done. So if we make our way
over to experiments and go to binary pipeline,
we can see that it took 14 minutes and 22
seconds, we can go here and just see some
additional information, there's nothing really
else to see we saw all the steps already ran,
so you can see them all here. Okay, and so let's
say we want to there's nothing under metrics, but
able to actually slog data points,
compare these data within across runs,
really did a single run, so there's nothing to
compare. So let's say we were happy with this,
and we want to deploy this model, what what
I'm going to do is go back to the designer,
click back here. And so now in the top right
corner, we can create our inference pipeline. So
I can remember who submits going to
run it, I don't want to run it again,
I just want to go ahead and create ourselves
a real time or batch pipeline, let's say real
time bi pipeline here. And what this will
do is it'll actually create a completely
different pipeline. So here's a completely
new one. But it's specifically designed to
do deployment. Okay, so this is now one was
for training the model. This one is actually
for taking in data and doing inference. Okay, so
what we can do is, we can go ahead and just submit
this. That's it, we'll put this under our binary
pipeline here. We'll go ahead and hit submit.
And I believe that we need a different kind
of compute here. I'm surprised that it's
even running. I guess it has a compute
there. So it's going to run and once it
finishes running that I believe
that we can go ahead and
deploy it. Okay, so let's just wait for that to
finish. All right. Alright, so after a little
while, there, we ran our inference pipeline. And
so it's definitely something that is ready for
use. The idea is that what we actually use, it's
going to go through this web service input to this
web service output, but not so important at this
level of certification. Let's see what it looks
like to go ahead and deploy it. So yep, we have
the option between a real time endpoint and an
existing endpoint. We don't have an endpoint
yet. So we'll just say, binary pipeline.
Okay. And notice we have the option
between wants it lowercase binary pipeline.
And we have the option between Azure Kubernetes
service and Azure Container instance,
it's a lot easier to deploy, I think, to container
instance. So because it will be waiting forever
for Kubernetes to start up. So we're going to do
container instance, we have some options like SSL
and things like that, not too worried about it.
So we're just going to go ahead and hit deploy.
Okay. And so that is going to go ahead and deploy
that. So we'll wait for this real time inference,
if we go over to our compute, it should spin up.
So this is for Eks. I don't know if it'll show up
here. I think only I've seen things under here.
But I think this will be for Azure Kubernetes
service. And I don't think we're gonna see it
show up under there. However, we do not need to
be running this anymore. So we'll go ahead and
delete the binary pipeline, because we're not,
we don't have it for any use right now. And we
might need to free it up for something else. Okay.
So go ahead and delete it, we don't need
it. And coming back to our pipeline,
or designer here, I'm just trying to
see where we can keep track of it.
I know that it's deploying. So waiting for real
time endpoint. So I'll see you back here when
this is done. Okay, takes a little bit of time.
Alright, so I think our pipeline is done. If we
make our way over to endpoints, there it is the
binary pipeline. If we wanted to go ahead there,
we could test the data. And so it actually
already has some pre loaded data for us.
We had test. It's nice that it fills it in a
we get some results back. Okay. So, I mean,
that we see like scored labels and income
and score probability. So things like that,
that is useful. So it's getting back all all
the results, but I don't think it has. Yeah,
it doesn't have scored labels and scored
probabilities, which is the value we want to
come back here. So There are endpoints, and that
is the end of our exploration with designer, okay?
Alright, so let's take a look at what it would
be to actually train a job programmatically
through the notebook. So remember, we saw these
samples over here. And so we saw this image
classification, m NIST. And this is a very
popular data set for doing computer vision.
And these are really great, if you want to really
learn you should really go through these and just
read through them, because they're, they're
probably very, very useful. I've done a lot of
this before. So for me, it's, it's just, it's not
too hard to figure out. But I've actually never
ran this one. So let's run it together. Again,
we want to be in Jupiter lab. So you can go here
and click it there or go to the compute. If it's
been a bit finicky. And just here, we'll get a tab
open here. And we'll see how this goes. So what I
want to do and is just make sure we're back here,
I can click into this one. And we have a few.
So there's part one, and then we have the deploy
stage. So let's look at training. I don't know
if we really need to deploy, but we'll give it a
read here. So in this tutorial, you train an ml
model under compute resource resources will be
training and training and deployment workflow via
the Azure Machine Learning service. In a notebook,
there's two parts to this. This is using
the amnesty data set and psychic learn.
And with Azure Machine Learning probably SDK, it's
a popular data set with 70,000, grayscale images,
each image is handwritten digits of 28
times by 28 times pixels representing
numbers from zero to nine, the goal is to create
multi class classifier to divide the digits in a
given image that represents. So we're gonna learn
a few things here, but let's just jump into it.
So the first thing is that we need to import
our packages. So here, it does that map
plot plot live in lines, just make sure that
when we print things that we visually see them,
we're going to NumPy and then matplotlib itself,
the Azure ML core, and then we're going to import
a workspace since we'll need one there. And
then I guess it just checks the version making
sure if we have the right version here. Okay, so
this is one point 28. Zero, it's pretty common,
even as an AWS, they'll have like a script in
here to update it in case it is out of date.
I'm surprised it didn't include it in here, but
that's okay. We'll scroll on down. And by the way,
we're using Python 3.6 Azure ML. If this is
the future, that you know, they might retire
the old one, you're using 3.8. But you know, to
generally work if it's in their sample data set,
I assume they try to maintain that. Okay, so
connect to a workspace. So create a workspace
object from an existing workspace reads the file
config dot JSON. So what we'll do is go run that
I assume it's kind of like a session. And so
here it says, It's figured found our workplace.
So really, it's just it's not creating
a workspace, it's just returning
the existing one so that we have it as a variable
here, create an experiment. So that's pretty
clear. We saw experiments in the auto ml and
the designer. So we'll just hit run there.
Okay. So we named it core ml. And we said
experiment. I wonder if it actually created
one yet. Let's go over to experiment to see if
it's there. So there's there cool, I was fast,
I thought it would like print something out,
but it didn't do anything there. So creator,
attach an existing compute resource by using Azure
Machine compute a managed service data scientists,
etc, etc. yada, yada, yada. So create a copy.
creation of a compute takes about five minutes.
So let's see what it's trying to create. So we
have some environment variables that wants to load
in I'm not sure how these are getting in here. I'm
not sure we're environment variables are set in
Jupiter, or even how they get fitted
in. But apparently they're somewhere.
But we have, it doesn't matter because these
are defaulting. So here's a CPU cluster,
zero and four, it's going to use a standard D two
v two, that is the cheapest one that we can run. I
kind of want something a little bit more powerful
just for myself. Just because I want this to be
done a lot sooner. But again, you know, if you're
don't have a lot of money, just stick with what's
there. Okay. So and this is CPU clusters. So if we
go here, I just want to see what our options are.
I'm
not sure why it's not showing us options here.
You don't have enough quota for the
following VM sizes. So it probably
it's because I'm running
more than one VM right now.
Yeah, so I've said I've hit my quota. Okay, so
like I probably would have to request for an hour.
So I think this is the one I'm using. What's the
difference here? This standard dv two v CPUs.
The same one, right? So request quota increase.
I don't know if this is incident or not,
I'd have to make a support ticket. All that's
going to take Long. So the thing is, is that
because the reason is is that I'm running the
auto ml and the designer and the designer in the
background here trying to create all the workshops
or the, the follow along at the same time. But
what I'll do is I'll just come back and when I'm
not running one of those other ones, then I will,
I'll come back here and continue on. But we're
just here at the step, we want to create a new
computer. Okay. All right, so I'm back and I freed
up one of my compute instances, if I go over here,
now I just have the one cluster instance for
my auto ml. But what we'll do here is again,
just read through this. So this will create a CPU
cluster zero to four nodes, standard G two v two,
I guess we'll just stick with what what is here,
I'm just reading through here, it looks like it
tries to find the compute target, it's going to
provision it, it will create the cluster called
pool for a minimum numbers of nodes for a specific
time. So wait for completion. So we'll go ahead
and hit play. And so that's going to go and create
us a new cluster. So we're just going to have to
wait a little while here for to create about five
minutes, and I'll see you back here in a moment.
Alright, so the cluster started up, if we go back
over here, we can see that it's confirmed, I don't
know why it was so quick, but it went pretty quick
there. So we're on the next section here, explore
the data. So download the emnes data set display
some sample images. So it's just talking about it
being the open data set. The code retrieves in the
file data set object, which is a subclass of data
set file data set references a single or multiple
files of any format in your data store. The class
provides you with the ability to download or mouth
files to your computer by creating a reference
to the data source location. Additionally, you
register the data set to your workspace for easy
retrieval. During training. There's a bit more
how tos, but we'll give it a good read here. So
we have the open data set and missed. It's kind
of nice that they have that reference there. So
we have a data folder, we make the directory, we
are getting the dataset, we download it, and then
we are registering it. So let's go ahead and run
that. Not sure how fast but it shouldn't take too
long as it's running. We'll go over here the left
hand side refresh, and we'll see if it appears.
Not as of yet. There it is. Go into here, maybe
explore the data. I'm not sure how it would
look like because these are all images, right?
Yeah, so they're in you byte Gz. So they're in
compressed files, we're not going to be able to
see within them but they're definitely there. We
know they're there. So that that is now registered
into our data set, display some sample images, so
load the compressed into a files into NumPy, then
use matplotlib plot 30 random images from the data
set from above note, the step requires load
data function, it's included in the utils. py
file is included in the sample folder, we
have it over here, we just double click,
very simple file to load data. And we'll go ahead
and run that. And it's pretty, pretty simple here.
So load data x train x test it are we setting up
our training and testing data here, it kind of
looks like it because it says train and test data.
That's when we usually see that kind of split.
And again, it's doing a random split.
So that sounds pretty good to me.
Let's show some randomly chosen images. Yeah, so
I guess they do set up the training data here.
And then down below, we're actually showing
the images. So here's some random images
train on a remote cluster. So for this task to
submit the job to run on the remote training
cluster to set up earlier submit your job.
Create the directory, create a training
script created scripts, run configuration, submit
the job. So first, we'll create our directory.
And notice it created this directory over here.
Because I guess it's going to put the training
file in there. And so this will actually write to
a training file. This makes quite a bit of sense.
So if we click into here, it should now have a
training file. It'll just give it a quick read,
see what's going on here. So a lot of times when
you create these training files you have to do
and this is the same if you're using AWS, like
when you're creating train, like or Sage maker,
you create a train file because it's part of
frameworks is just how the frameworks work.
But you'll have these arguments.
So it could be like parameters to
run for training. And there could be a whole
sorts of ones here. Here they are loading in the
training and testing data. So it's the same stuff
we saw earlier when we were just viewing the data.
Here it's doing a logistic regression. It's using
lib. So linear, maybe linear learning model.
They're sitting multiclass on that there. And
so what's going to do is fit so fit is actually
performing the training. And then what it's going
to do is make a prediction on the test set. That
it's going we're going to get accuracy so we're
getting kind of a score. So notice that it's using
accuracy As a valuation metric, I suppose, right.
And then at the end, we're going to dump the data,
a lot of times, like you have to save the model
somewhere. So they're outputting, the actual
weights of the neural network and all other
stuff. It's a plk file. I don't know what that is.
But if you're using like TensorFlow, you would
use TensorFlow serving at the end of this,
a lot of times frameworks, like pytorch, or
TensorFlow, or MX net, they'll have a serving
layer. But since we're just using scikit, learn,
which is very simple, it's just going to dump
out that file into our outputs, this is going
to probably run a container. So this outputs
isn't going to necessarily be on the outputs into
here, it's more like the outputs of the container.
And a lot of times the container will then
place this somewhere. So like, it'll be saved
on the container. But it'll be passed out
to the register or, or something like that,
like model registry. So anyway, we ran this,
so that generated the file, we don't want to
keep on running this multiple times, I probably
just overwrite the file. So it's not a big deal.
Here, it says notice how the script gets saved
in the data model. So here, it's saying the data
data folder, I guess we didn't look at that. So if
we go top here, I didn't see this is data folder.
wasn't really paying attention to where that
was. Because it looks like where more so it's
loading the data in. So here, it saves the data
that put anything written to this directory is
automatically uploaded to your workspace. So I
guess that's just how it works. So it probably
will end up in here then. So you tell py reference
the training script to load the dataset correctly,
and copy the file over. So we will run this to
copy the file over. So I'm guessing did it put
it into here? I'm just wondering, yeah, so it just
put it in there. Because when it actually packages
it for the container, it's going to bring that
fall over because it's a dependency. So configure
the training jobs. So create a script, run
config, the directory that contains the script,
the compute target, the training script, train,
file, etc. Sometimes like in other frameworks,
we'll just call them estimators. But here's just
called a script run config. So I'm just trying to
see what it's doing. So scikit learn is the
dependency. Okay, sure. We'll just hit run.
Okay. And then down below here, we have script
run config. So it looks like we're passing our
arguments that we're saying this is our data
folder, which is apparently here, we're mounting
it. And then we're setting regularization to 0.5.
Sometimes you'll pass in dependencies in here as
well, I guess these are technically our parameters
that are getting configured up here at the top,
right. But sometimes you'll have dependencies
if you're in it, including other files here.
And I guess that's up here, right? So see where
it says environment. And then we're saying include
the Azure ML defaults into psychic learn, and
stuff like that. And so then it gets passed in the
end. Does that make sense to me, we haven't ran
that yet. Because we don't see any number here.
Submit the job to the cluster. So let's
go ahead and do that. says it returns a
preparing a running state as soon as the job
is completed. So it's in a starting state.
Monitor remote run. So in total, the first
run takes 10 minutes, but the second run
is as long as the dependencies and Azure
ML. Farming don't change the same images
reuse and hence the Start Here Start Time is much
faster. Here's what's happening while you wait.
The image creation a Docker image is created
matching the Python environment specified by
the Azure ML environment. The image is built and
stored in the ACR, the Azure Container Registry
associated with your workspace. Let's go
take a look and see if that's the case.
Sometimes, like resources aren't visible to
us, so I'm just curious, do we actually see it?
Okay. And Yep, there it is.
Okay, so that did not lie.
So especially your workspace immigration uploading
takes about five minutes the stage happens once.
For each Python environment. Since the
containers cache subsequent runs during
image creation, a logs are stemmed to the run
history, you can monitor the image creation
process process using these logs wherever those
are, if you if the remote cluster requires more
nodes to execute the run than currently available,
additional nodes are added automatically. Scaling
takes typically takes about five minutes. And
I've seen this before, where if you're in your
compute here, and sometimes they'll just say
like scaling because there's just not enough.
So running in the stage, the necessary scripts
and files are sent to the compute target than the
data source or a mounted copy. The entry script
is run Sentry script is actually the train.py
file. While the job is running STD out in the
files is in the logs directory or stem to the
run history. You can monitor the runs progress
using In these logs, the dot outputs directory
of the run is copied over to the run history in
your workspace. So you can access these results.
You can check the progress of a running job in
multiple ways. This tutorial uses the Jupiter
widget. So looks like we can run this, watch
the progress. So maybe we will run that. And
so it's actually showing us the progress.
That's kind of cool. I really like that.
So it's just a little widget, join
us all the things that it's doing.
Let's go take a look and see what we can
see under experiments and our run pipeline.
He was talking about things like
outputs and things like that. So over
here in the outputs and logs, I'm just
curious. Is it this is the same thing?
I'm not sure if this is the this tails. Yeah,
it does tail, it just moves so we can actually
monitor it from here. I guess that's what
it was talking about. so here we can see
that it's setting up Docker, it's actually
building a Docker image. And then I'm not sure
did it send it to I mean, it's on ACR already.
I think. It looks like it's still installing
extracting packages. So maybe it's actually
running on the image now. So just wait there, we
pop back over here. You know, we can see probably
the same information is identical. Yep, it is.
So we're three minutes in, it's probably
not that fun to watch it in real time and,
and talk about it. So let's just wait until
it's done. I'll see you back then. Okay.
Alright, so I'm about 17 minutes in here. I'm
not seeing any more movement here. So it could be
that it is done. It does say if you run this next
step here will wait for completion. Specify show
output to true for verbose log. So here actually
did output a moment ago. So maybe it actually
was done. I just ran it twice. So I'm not sure if
that's going to cause me issues there. So because
I can't run the next step, unless I stopped
this guy individually cancel this one here.
I think I can just hit interrupt the colonel,
there we go. Okay, so I think that it's done.
Okay, because it's 18 minutes in. And I
don't see any more logging in here. It's
just not very clear. And also, the logs, we
just have a lot of stuff going on here. Like,
this is so much. So you know, if we were keeping
keeping pace, we probably would have saw all these
credit. Yeah, so another, we just had a few more
outputs there. But I think that it's done. Okay.
It's just there's nothing definitively saying
like, done. Do you know I'm saying and then
up here, it doesn't say, oh, oh, I guess
it does say that. It's done. All right.
So yeah, I just never ran it with the school. So
I just don't know. So I guess it does definitively
say that. I already ran this. So we don't need to
run that. Again. I just feel like we'll get stuck
there. So let's take a look at the metrics.
So regularization rate is 0.5 accuracy is
nine to nine is pretty good. The last step
is train the script wrote in the output S.
S, sk learn, I want to see if it's actually in
our environment here. I don't think it is. So
I'll put this somewhere. It's in our workspace
somewhere, but it's just not. We just don't
know where it's right here. Okay. So they'll
put it the actual model right there. And so
you can see the associated files
that are ran, okay, we'll run it.
register the work model and space that you
can work with other collaborators. Sure.
So if I click on that here, and we go back over to
our models, it is now registered over here. Okay.
So we're done part one. I don't want to do all
these other parts. Training is enough as it is,
but let's just take a look at the deploy
stage. Okay, so for prerequisites.
We're saying have a workspace we have
our we are loading our registered model.
Okay, we register it where you have
to import packages, we are going to
create scoring script, deploy to an ACI
model, test the model, if you want to do this,
you can go through all the steps, it does talk
about confusion matrix, and that is something that
can show up on the exam is actually talking
about a confusion matrix. But we do cover that
in lecture content. So you generally understand
what that is. But, you know, I'm just I'm too
tired. I don't want to run through all this.
And there's not a whole lot of value other than
reading, reading through it yourself here.
So I think we're all done here. Okay.
Okay, one service we forgot to check out was data
labeling. So let's go over there and give that a
go. So I'm going to go ahead and create ourselves
a new project, I'd say my labeling project and
we can say Whether we want to classify images or
text, we have multi class multi label bounding box
segmentation, let's go with multi class. I'll
go back here for a second multiclass. Whoops.
I don't know if we create dataset, but we
could probably upload some local files.
Let's say, my Star Trek dataset does
let us choose the image file type here. Good.
So these are images. Gonna tell us what here.
It's very finicky this input here.
file this it references a single
or multiple files in your public data store
or private public URL. Okay, so we go next.
If we can upload files directly, that'd be nice.
Ooh, upload a folder. I like that. So what we'll
do is we do have some images in the free AI
here, under Cognitive Services assets we have
we'll go back here and we'll say I
think objects would be the easiest.
But we just want a folder right?
So yeah, we'll just take objects.
Yep, we'll upload the 17 files. Yep, we'll just
let it stick to that path. That seems fine to me.
We'll go ahead and create it. And
so now we have a data set there,
we'll go ahead and select that data set, we'll
say next, your data says periodically check for
new data points and data points will be added
as tasks, it doesn't matter. We're only doing
this for test. Enter the list of labels
that we have TMG DS nine, Voyager tasks
toss. That's the types of Star Trek
episodes. Label which Star Trek series
The images from, say next. I don't
want enabled but you can have auto
enabled assistant labeler. I'm gonna
say No, we'll create the project.
Okay, I'll just wait for that. Great.
I'll see you back here in a moment. Okay.
All right. So I'm back here actually didn't have
to wait long. I think it instantly runs. I just
assumed like I was waiting for a state that says
completed. But it's not something we have to do.
So we have zero to 17 progress, we're going to
go in here, we're going to go label some data,
we can view the instructions. It's not showing
up here. But that's fine. If we go to tasks,
we can start labeling. So what season is
this from or series, this is Voyager, we'll
hit submit. This is Voyager we'll hit submit.
This is toss, we'll hit submit. This is TMG.
This is TMG. This is DS nine,
DS nine, Voyager. wager TMG.
Ds nine, you get the idea though, you've got
some options here like change the contrast, if
someone can't see the photo, or rotate it, this
is Voyager, Voyager TMG, DS, nine, Voyager,
Voyager. And we're done. So we'll
go back to our labeling job here,
we'll see we have the breakdown there in our data
set is labeled. We can export our data set CSV,
cocoa, as your ml data set, I believe that means
it will go back into the data sets over here. This
will make our lives a little bit easier. Go back
to data labeling. Okay. So you just grant people
access to the studio, they'd be able to just go
in here and jump into that job. Okay. If we go
over to the data set, I believe we should have a
labeled version of it now. So my labeling project.
So I believe that is the labeled stuff here,
right? Yep, so it's labeled. So there you go.
We're all done Azure machine learning. And
so all that's left is to do some cleanup.
Okay, so we're all done with Azure Machine
Learning if we want to and go to our compute,
and just kill the services we have
here. Now, if we go to the resource
group and delete everything, it'll
take all these things down anyway,
but I'm just gonna go with a paranoid so I'm
gonna just manually do this, okay. hit Delete.
Okay, so we'll go back to portal dot Azure
calm. And I'm going to go to my resource groups,
and everything is contained. It should
be all contained within my studio,
just be sure to check these other ones for that.
And we can see all the stuff that we spun up.
We'll go ahead and hit Delete resource
group. I don't know if it includes like,
because I don't see like Container Registry,
right? So I know like it puts stuff there.
I guess it does. It's this Container Registry.
So that's pretty much everything right?
And I'll take down everything So, and if you're
paranoid, all you can do is go to all resources
and double check over here, because if there's
anything running, it'll show up here, okay?
But that's pretty much it. And so
just delete and we're all done.
Hey, this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro, and we're
on to the AI 900 cheat sheet and this one is seven
pages long, so let's get to it. At
the top of our list, we're starting
with artificial intelligence and machine that
can perform jobs that mimic human behavior.
Machine learning a machine that gets better at
a task, explicit programming, deep learning and
machine that has artificial neural nets. Inspired
by the human brain to solve complex problems. a
data scientist is a person with multidisciplinary
skills in math statistics, predictive modeling,
machine learning to make future predictions.
data set is a logical grouping of units of data
that are closely related or share the same data
structure. Examples of this would be m&s and cocoa
data labeling the process of identifying raw data,
so images, text files, videos, and adding one or
more meaningful and informative labels to provide
context to a machine learning model can learn
supervised learning data that has been labeled
for training, unsupervised learning data that
has not been labeled. An ml model needs to do its
own labeling, reinforcement learning, so there is
no data and there's an environment and an ml model
generates data with many attempts to reach a goal.
You have neural networks also abbreviate to nn,
a network of nodes organized into layers of input
hidden output that is used to train ml models.
We have deep neural nets. So dnn, a neural net
that has three or more hidden layers to their deep
learning backpropagation moves backwards through
neural net adjusting weights to improve outcome
on the iteration. This is how a neural net learns
loss function, a function that compares the ground
truth to the prediction to determine the error
rate, how bad the network performed, activation
functions and algorithm applied to a hidden layer
node at that affects connected output. So Arielle
use a very common one, you have a dense layer,
this is when the next layer increases the
amount of nodes you have a sparse layer,
this is one of the next layer decreases the amount
of nodes, you have GPUs that especially designed
to quickly render high resolution images and
videos concurrently. Commonly used for non
graphical tasks such as machine learning and
scientific computing. You have CUDA which is
a parallel computing platform and API by Nvidia
that allows developers to use CUDA enabled GPUs
for general purpose computing, also known as GPU
GPU. On to the second sheet here for ml pipeline,
we have pre processing, I didn't outline this
in the course. So I'm going to just do that now.
So preparing data and feature engineering before
passing data to ml model for training inference,
you might have data cleaning, so this
is correcting errors within the data set
that could negatively impact the results data
reduction, reducing the amount of data or applying
dimensionality reduction to reduce
the dimensions of inputted vectors,
feature engineering, transforming data into
numerical vectors to be ingested by the ML model,
sampling or resampling pouncing a data set to
be uniform across labels by adding or removing
records. post processing translate the output
of an ml model back into human readable format,
training.
In the process of training the model serving the
process of deploying the model to an endpoint to
be used for inference inference invoking
an ml model by sending requests expecting
back a prediction, we have real time endpoints
that optimize optimize for small or single
item payloads. Returns results quickly usually
uses a dedicated running server. batch transform
optimized for larger batch predictions server
runs only for the duration of the batch. There's
forecasting make a prediction with relevant
data analysts of trends edit stock guessing,
predicting make a future prediction with
without relevant data using statistics to
predict future outcomes more of guessing
using decision theory. For performance
and evaluation metrics are used to evaluate
different machine learning algorithms just to
select a few here classification we have accuracy
f1 score precision recall, for regression metrics
we have MSE, our MSE, ma remember mean squared
errors okay. Jupyter Notebooks a web based
application for author and documents combined live
code narrative texts equations of visualizations.
classification is the process of finding
a function to divide a label data set into
classes and categories. A confusion matrix is
a table to visualize the model predictions of
predictive versus ground truth actual take the
time to go look up how confusion matrix work,
because they will absolutely ask you questions
on the exam for the 900. Okay, regression is
the process of finding a function to correlate a
labeled data set into continuous variable numbers.
clustering is the process of grouping unlabeled
data based on similarity and differences. Okay,
on to our third sheet here Cognitive Services
an umbrella AI service that enables customers
to access multiple AI services with an API key
an endpoint we have the category of decision so
anomaly detector identify potential problems early
on content moderator detect potential offensive
or unwarranted content personalizer create
rich personalized experience for everyone.
language understanding so build natural language
understanding into the app spots in our devices
q&a maker create a conversational Question and
Answer layer over the data. Text Analytics. detect
sentiment key phrases and add named entries.
translator detect translate and more than 90
supported languages. For speech we have speech to
text transcribe audible speech into readable text
text to speech convert text to lifelike speeches
for more natural interfaces speech translation
integrate real time speech translation of your
apps, speak recognition identify verify the people
speaking based on the audio for vision we have
computer vision so analyze content and images and
videos custom vision customized image recognition
to fit your business needs, face detect the
detect and identify people and emotions and
images. Knowledge mining is a discipline in AI
that uses a combination of intelligence services
to quickly learn from vast amounts of information.
And there's three things to this there's ingest of
content from a range of sources using connectors
to the first and and third party data stores
enrich the content with the AI capabilities
that let you extract information find patterns,
deep understanding explore the newly indexed data
via search boxes, existing business applications
and data visualizations onto our fourth sheet.
We have Mark stuff AI principles, so this
is responsible AI remember there's six. So
fairness an AI system should treat all people
fairly reliability and safety AI systems should
perform reliability and safety, privacy and
security AI systems should be secure and respect
privacy. inclusiveness AI system should
empower everyone engaged people, transparency,
AI systems should be understandable accountability
people should be accountable for the AI systems,
common ml workloads. So for this, we have anomaly
detection is the process of finding outliers with
a data set called anomaly. Computer Vision
is when we use ml neural nets to gain high
level understanding of digital images and videos.
And LP is the is the machine learning that can
understand the contents of a corpus or body of
text. conversational AI is technology that can
participate in conversations with humans.
I know it feels like we're repeating the
same thing quite in different ways. But that's
the way we're going to learn well here, okay.
Azure Machine Learning service allows you to
provision ml studio to build and maintain ml
models and pipelines. We have authors so
either that we have notebooks that Jupyter
notebooks and ID to write Python code to
build ml models. Remember, you can launch
it in Jupiter labs and VS code as well probably
once you have an example just so you know,
auto ml completely automated process
to build and train an ml model,
designer visual drag and drop designer construct
and build pipelines. We have data sets of data
that you can upload, which will be used for
training data can be versioned. Open datasets
are publicly hosted datasets are commonly used for
learning how to build ml models. experiments are
logical grouping of runs, runs our ML tasks that
perform on virtual machines or containers pipeline
so ml workflows you have built or have used in
the designer, you have a training pipeline. So
pipelines to build in Train and ml model inference
pipelines pipelines that are used to train
that use a trained model to make a prediction
on real data. Then you have models as a model
registry containing trained models that can be
deployed endpoints. When you deploy a model,
it's hosted on an accessible endpoints the REST
API. So real time endpoints invokes an ml model
for inference pipeline endpoint, invokes
that running on a pipeline. So for ci CD,
under manage, we have compute the underlying
computing instances used for notebooks,
training inference, so we have compute instances,
that all workstations that data scientists use to
work with the data models. This is generally
for your notebooks, computer clusters,
scalable clusters for virtual machines on demand
processing of experimental code, so training
and pre processing, inference clusters, deployment
targets for predictive services that use for train
models. So for inference, attached compute links
to existing Azure compute resources, such as
virtual machines, Azure data, bricks, clusters,
there's another one in there, but it's not gonna
show up an exam probably a patchy Spark,
but I guess it's covered under databricks.
So for environments that reproduce pre
reproducible Python environment for machine
learning experts or experiments, data stores
securely connect to your storage service on Azure
without putting your authentication credentials
in so it has Blob Storage file share data,
data lake storage Gen two, as your SQL data as
your Postgres MySQL database data labeling have
humans and ml assisted labeling to label your data
for supervised learning human and loop labeling,
machine learning since the data data labeling,
we have linked services so external services that
you can connect to a workspace such as Azure
synapse analytics, I think that's the only
way you can connect right now, then for text
analytics. So now we're out of the Azure Machine
Learning Services, we're ingesting the cognitive
services so text analytics, sentiment analysis,
find out what people think of your brand or
topic. Labels include negative, positive, mixed
or neutral confidence scores ranging from zero
to one opinion mining granular information about
the opinions related to aspects granular data
with a subject and opinion tied to a sentiment.
key phrase extraction quickly identifies the
main concepts in text. Language detection
detects the language, input text is written in
named entity recognition. ner detects words and
phrases mentioned in unstructured text that can
be associated with one or more sentiment types.
We have Louis or Luis language understanding
a no code ml service to build natural language
into apps, bots and IoT devices. Use NLU the
ability to transform a linguistic statement to
a representative that enables you to understand
your users naturally, Louis key schemas component
so we have intentions to user what the
user is asking for. So Louis app contains
a nun intent entities, what parts of the entity
intent is used to determine the answer utterances
examples of the user input that includes intent
and entities who trained the ML model to match
predictions against the real user input for
q&a maker generate a bot from a URL PDF,
and it's supposed to be do cx for docs, that's
a spelling mistake, then go the doc x file,
multi turn conversation, so follow up
prompts to narrow a specific answer
to chat personalized canned responses for
Azure bot service allow you to host bots.
So you have the Bot Framework SDK, which is an
end to end SDK to build, test, publish, connect,
evaluate bots, that's the entire pipeline that
they describe Bot Framework composer a desktop
application to design bots, leverage the Bot
Framework SDK, so there you go, that's the
whole cheat sheet. Usually, I would break it up
for service but there's a lot of intermixing. So
that's why I did it this way. But, you know,
good luck on your exam, and I hope you pass